foreign
yeah we're gonna take care of that
oh wait this is the wrong shade
um
at least I don't have to put other
people
um
[Laughter]
no okay what we're doing we're waiting
for all our members to be here uh while
we're waiting though I want to let folks
on the committee those that are on the
public school infrastructure
commission this is a commission which
allocates our self as security and
safety in our schools the next meeting
of that will be a March 31 at 11 o'clock
over at Granite State College
at the building there that's where we
meet the folks on that are are folks
like the commissioner from Homeland
Security Robert Buxton the commissioner
of Education Frank edelblue several
senators and uh reps as well so we will
be meeting on March 31 11 o'clock over
that's where we have the allocation for
additional dollars for security in the
schools and the schools apply for these
grants
we have presently spent close to 43
million dollars in Safety and Security
in our schools which is a higher per
capita than other states are doing
so New Hampshire should be applauded for
that okay it looks like we have
two other committees which I'll be soon
scheduling here one is the legislative
oversight committee for improvement and
assessment in schools that be towards
latter part of March I don't have a
specific date yet attentively looking at
March 27th
and also looking at a meeting for the
higher education study committee which
we have that deals with post-secondary
education most likely on the 27th also
one in the morning one in the afternoon
but we have not yet I'm trying to get
so while we're waiting I was a little
bit late because I was outside listening
to the Manchester High School Central
thing and they were so excellent things
there yeah yeah I saw that Central was
great for me
you're completely unbiased
representative Cornell Wednesdays when
you're working with the CTE advisory
Council we'd like to get a trip down to
alverne too okay and and uh you might
yeah you you can work with um Terry
Wolfe
for the public we really had a good day
yesterday in terms of some of the
priorities for this committee we were
able to acquire additional dollars for
the Career Technical education tuition
and transportation that was a real jump
forward
um uh another uh 4.4 million dollars for
the next biennium that brings up 11.2
million per per year uh we've been
funding it 9 million in the past and
this will help out with the
transportation costs Transportation
reimbursement by the Senate by the state
for CTE from the sending school to the
receiving Center is 10 cents per mile
per pupil it doesn't pay for the bus
the other thing which we had occur we
had fiscal capacity disparity that bill
I got a good positive light yesterday
from the division two and we're really
pleased with that also we had a bill
that dealt with additional weighted
formula for special education diversity
that also got the green light and
there's at least another 12 million
dollars pumped into that as well
um so we're seeing some uh in the
Medicaid direct is being looked at uh
currently and um I I believe that that's
going to come out satisfactory as well
so all that will really help us out in
terms of where we're going with our
support of public education in the state
looks like we're all here right now
so uh HB 629 is not on the uh list that
you have in front of you for today
however it's a bill we skipped yesterday
at the end of the day and due to the
fact we are getting out of here around
five o'clock 5 30 somewhere around that
hour and had gone since early in the
morning and so we are going to take 629
up first and then get down into our
calendar for today which starts with
cacr7 so I'd like to recognize represent
McDonald for a
motion please on 629 629 is a bill
establishing a student Bill of Rights
thank you Mr chair I move that we find
hb629 establishing a student Bill of
Rights and expedient to legislate is
there a second
represent Belcher seconds that so a
medical clerk motion made by uh
represent McDonald and second by
representative Belcher
McDonald you're recognized to speak to
your motion thank you I believe this
should be itl because although it was
well intended to as was said by the
prime sponsor put the focus back on
students this was really went about in
the wrong way as no students were asked
for any input and there was no attempt
to made to get student input and that
was my biggest concern but in addition
it seems that rights were picked to be
included in a student Bill of Rights but
it's a non-exhaustive list of all the
rights included so my concern is with
the rights that were not included why or
some picked and why are some others and
they're not a certain particular order
of the rides being listed there's many
concerns regarding that and members on
this committee I know some would agree
that there is a concern by what was
included as compared to what was not
included so thank you thank you very
much from the maker of the second thank
you Mr chair and I I have obviously
similar similar concerns but I also have
a lot of concerns about what is listed
in this document
um first of all it goes right to the
principle of what is a right for
instance line 12 of page one identifies
the Privileges of the Constitution to
which people are entitled constitution
does not contain any privileges it
recognizes pre-existing natural rights
of persons
further issues involve unqualified
freedom to assemble which could easily
be interpreted to allow students to
assemble for political reasons at any
time including during the school day
and perhaps most dangerously this bill
would assign students and this is this
is law this is not just we're not
putting opinions out there in this thing
this is law when you assign a student
the unqualified and unabridged right to
private conscience in religious matters
you are effectively telling their
parents that they have no right to
direct their religious education they
can refuse to go to church and anything
else they want to do when we're talking
about minors here miners have rights but
they don't have all of the full natural
rights inherent to a full adult with
adult agency we have to recognize that
in document like this thank you thank
would you please call the roll
the the bill is HB 629 this is a bill
dealing with the establishing a student
Bill of Rights
Vice chairman cordelli
yes
representative leckis
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal yes representative quartz
yellow yes representative Myler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner nope Representative luno no
representative Ellison no representative
Woodcock no representative Hall no
representative Balboni no Representative
cascadden no representative Damon
no chairman Ladd yes
representative Tanner I'd like to offer
an OTP uh motion and I also have an
amendment
is there a second
reference seconds the motion made by
represent Tanner uh represent Tanner
you're recognized
okay it's it's Amendment
zero two three two h
the amendment we're doing is zero two
does everybody have a copy of that in
front of you right now
represent Tanner would you please walk
us through that Amendment certainly or
is I do have a motion to put the
amendment on the table you did
um I'd like to yeah I said I'd like to
put a motion on okay OTP okay is there a
second on the on the amendment no okay
the same post so Tanner Miler for the
mem go ahead please representative so uh
when I submitted the bill originally to
uh OLS uh what you're seeing is what the
original bill was and what they did was
um the the person that was the
um lawyer uh drafting lawyer uh cut out
the first part of it uh which is a
statement of findings and so this
amendment
um reinstates the statement of findings
which gives
some context I think to the rest of the
bill and
um as I said when I presented this bill
that
um this is meant to get the focus back
on students the the people that are the
product of Education the people that it
should be the focus of Education
um and I appreciate that some people
fear that this might embolden some of
the students but um the every part of
this bill is actually found in
Constitution either the New Hampshire
Constitution the U.S Constitution or
federal law around adequate and free
education so
um
I think it's uh important that that as a
committee and as a state house we
recognize the the students in our
classes and and uh
you know we've had some great bills come
through here that really are going to
make a difference in students lives and
this is just one to give them
um some confidence that that they are
recognized as well
are there questions from the committee
represent Belcher
yeah that's just the first question
because I'm reading some of this and
there's a lot of
there's a lot of language in here that I
would consider somewhat vague or or I'm
not sure how to interpret all of it but
I I guess I would ask is this coming
from an organization or some or of some
kind is this a model legislation of some
sort
this legislation was
um something that I had read about
um on that on ncls and
um this was some of the some of the
languages from that but other languages
also locally devised and like I said
it's to give context
I noticed that the LBA does not have a
physical note on it it does have FN
attached to the bill have you any
projection what the costs are for this
I am totally uh so much as to why
the rights delineated in the
Constitution both the New Hampshire
Constitution and the Federal
Constitution are what are called
negative rights you have the right from
certain things the right from intrusion
of government
Etc
um
a number at which a number of these are
and clearly based on one or both of the
Constitutions but other ones are a right
to something and nobody has a right to
something that requires an act of
somebody else and there are a number of
items here that are what are called
positive
um
rights which are not guaranteed by our
constitutions and which require somebody
else to act
and that was never the intent of any of
our founder Founders and it is very much
against my basic belief system that
anybody has the right to require another
person to act and that would be my
biggest objection to this is those lines
that require somebody else to act
somebody else to pay somebody else to do
things
I don't believe one person can require
that of somebody else thank you further
further discussion yes representative
Damon
thank you Mr chair
um
I'm a little puzzled representative
Lucas are when you speak about
sorry forgetting the term you just used
positive rights thank you
um
like 31 on the first page through six or
so on the second page is that what
um
starting around 26 where you're now
requiring other people to act to be
taxed to all of those things as a right
it may be something that we have agreed
to do but it is not a right
may I continue yes so first of all
there's nothing here about taxation in
that part
um
I guess I'm just on a completely
different page than you are I think
further discussion representative Tanner
I'm also confused
um some of these like the ones about uh
education there's um certainly in our
constitution in the New Hampshire
Constitution
there is a mention of the right for
education but we've also federally and
also State have a
standard that has been passed and is in
law that says children have a right to a
free and adequate education
that children with disabilities
um have different rights under under
federal law so I think what you're I I
am not going to think what you do you
mean that you your personal belief is
different than what's in this bill
rather than uh the fact that it needs a
physical note because it's you feel that
um
these rights uh are not in statute and
and and need
um I don't understand need a fiscal
responsibility to them
in the Constitution it doesn't say that
what it says is that we shall cherish
and encourage
education which is quite different from
what the courts decided from what a
specific few judges decided it meant
that that meant we had to pay for
Education now we have as a legislature
and we have in towns decided to do that
but that isn't because it is a right it
is because we decided to do that and I
my objection is to calling it a right
and saying that a student has a right to
that the student has that because the
town has decided to support that or for
the state money because the state has
decided to spend money and support that
not because of a right nobody has a
right to insist that somebody else do
something and you are insisting
that they have the right to have other
people pay for their education
yes so
you're adjust you're objecting to the
word right how would you state that
since the courts have decided and the
the based on our Constitution that that
in fact is what happens that a child has
the right or whatever word you want to
put in there
to receive a free and adequate education
in the state of New Hampshire
I would say that they were hyperactive
judges a few of them
what you would place in that sentence
other than right I would leave that out
I would not put that in a student Bill
of Rights because it does not go along
with our constitutional rights that's
what I would do there are a number of
things that are in here that follow our
accounts
that don't
um just answer it and you're done you're
done and no follow-up questions
representative cascadden thank you maybe
I can add some clarity for this bill
that really reinforces that any student
has the right to attend a public school
in other words unlike non-public schools
every student is admitted it doesn't
matter what the need it doesn't matter
what any of the classifications are but
every single student is admitted to a
public institution and that's not always
the case so I don't know if that helps
clarify
the right I think they have that right
now but I think there's a perception out
there that you know
with Choice which is fine people have
choice
but there is a difference
with how you're funding
mechanisms are and how
the public school must service every
single child
I I have a question for representative
Tanner here on line 36 and 37 on page
two it says the right to access without
tuition
each resident School District's K-12
basic education program for students of
qualifying age
I'm a k through
8th District
and we have agreements that are made
with us receiving schools to tuition our
students to those schools and that's
very typical throughout this state
the local board has the authority to
approve the receiving school as one of
their tuition schools
we also have numerous places within the
state right now
where the local school board that's
sending school board has approved
certain schools where students are sent
but they've also capped their tuition
let's say they cap it at twenty thousand
and you have a receiving school that's
also jumped from twenty thousand to
twenty thousand five hundred dollars
some of those districts are allowing
the parent to pay that difference
others are saying if we don't pay the
full freight then you're not going to go
there
so what are you implying here by this
section of law
um
I I need to have a better understanding
of the the where you're going with item
a here on line 36.
so the Claremont decision uh said we
hold that part 2 article 83
imposes a duty on the state to provide a
constitutionally adequate education to
every educable child in the public
schools in New Hampshire and to
guarantee adequate funding that's
Claremont versus the government uh
governor in
um
1993. that that's a court decision and
so even even if you only go to eighth
grade you're still your town and your
taxpayers are still
responsible for providing a
constitutionally adequate education to
every educable child in Residence within
your area okay now I'm going to follow
that up with another question then so we
have tuition agreements in this
particular hypothetical District talk
with receiving schools a b and c
and a and b fall within the tuition cap
C doesn't But A and B provide all the
services that are required by the
opportunity for an adequate education
so the student has that opportunity
provided to him or her
but the parent says well I also want to
go to C and I'm willing to pay the 500.
are they being denied the opportunity
for an adequate education
I think that what we're talking about is
not about the student Bill of Rights I
think we're talking about uh actually a
bill that we have coming up later in the
in the session uh or in today about
um vouchers and about
um payments uh to other schools uh that
are not within but each each district
um should in my opinion by law have an
anchor school that's a public school
that's uh free and it performs an
adequate education doesn't mean that
they have to have a whole bunch of
choices although we do have Choice
within our um educational setting so I
just think that that's
okay I'm just trying to get a little
clarification this is just the um so
you've used the word anchor which I
appreciate that so that
um we're we're not talking of a voucher
program here at all we're talking about
a whole different tuition type program
that's in existence throughout the state
right now
and the way this is written it could be
interpreted to deny some students which
are attending from these k8s or k-6s or
whatever we may have the opportunity to
continue going where they're going this
isn't a denial bill this is a uh bill
that states what their right is what
what they have every student that's
educable in the state of New Hampshire
has a right to a free and adequate
education and that has to be provided by
the local community and and how they do
that
um they no no child in that particular
Community should be forced to pay extra
parents should be paid
forced to pay extra money to go to a
private school
so last question I have for you then I I
don't want to get this back and forth
myself but so if it's provided that they
have the option
to go to a b or c and they choose C
knowing that they're going to get
transportation to a of course high
school students are not necessarily
guaranteed Transportation but the
district May provide that to a where all
those services but they still choose to
go to be
are you supportive of that concept I
think I think that is that is a choice
bill that is a that is part of the EFA
or the choice no that's not not
it's part of the it's part of the
croydonville that originally set up but
but that is part of one of the bills
that we're going to be talking about
later and this this is not to
identify and
restrict it is simply a statement of a
Bill of Rights it's the basic thing and
then whatever the legislature does on
top of that as long as each educable
child
has the ability to attend
uh free and adequate education
opportunity the opportunity yeah
representative cascadden um I was just
thinking your local school board
policies
should have that clearly spelled out
um there's one on admission of Resident
students
and however your district is structured
you could have potentially have language
in there already that determines whether
the district is going to allow that to
occur if the parent wants to pay the
difference and you should also have a
policy that talks about non-residents
and what authorities they have to either
attend your school or the school of
their choice but the district should
already have policies in there that
clearly describe what options families
have
within that District yeah representative
cordelli uh Belcher
as a a parent I have a problem with a
number of these so-called rights in here
I'm looking at Roman 3 on page two
um
uh does my child have a right to free
speech in my house
um I know of many instances where um I
denied my child uh free speech in my
home
um and how about the right of personal
privacy
um you know we had uh our computer in a
public space we could look at what was
going on
um in a school personal privacy does
that mean that the school or uh
um law enforcement cannot search lockers
anymore
um I think that there are a great many
things in here that were
prescribing rights to minors that go
well beyond what uh I as a parent would
want to provide to my child my children
representative uh Belcher
thank you Mr chair and I appreciate
those comments from rep for daily so I
won't belabor any of those points but I
would like to take a look at the new
section the statement of findings
especially under Roman three
um where I or I'm going to suggest that
this this this uh statement of Rights is
actually deeply confusing the concept of
rights with privileges
first of all so it actually says
privilege is right here so again I I
would I would make the point that the
constitution does not contain privileges
it recognizes pre-existing natural
rights that are inherent to each person
I happen to believe that as image
bearers of God we do but each person can
decide for themselves why each person
has an inherent dignity and rights but
they're inherent to a person they're not
granted by the Constitution they're just
recognized
and the problem comes where it suggests
down here that these rights can go
through Evolution and interpretation
and that's just not something that
rights are subject to rights either
exist or they do not they do not evolve
they are unchanging at all times and in
all places
and to confuse that concept with
privileges that are granted by
government puts us into a position where
we have we can lose these rights with a
51 majority deciding we don't have them
anymore
so that's that's my big issue with this
representative
thank you Mr chair I am very confused
about the fact that we have compulsory
education in the state of New Hampshire
to the age of 18. so children are in
essence forced to attend school
the parents are have an obligation to
determine which school or which type of
school their children attend so now
we're going to turn around and give
those same that same group of people who
we are forcing into a situation forcing
into an education and we're going to
tell them what their rights are well if
you look at page two line 22 the very
first thing I would have done as a high
school student would be to assemble my
fellow students and say that I no longer
have a duty to I'm going to exercise my
right of petition and peaceful assembly
to tell you that I will not be going to
school nor should it be compulsory any
longer
one of the state troopers coming after
you
representative McDonald
thank you um an additional point that
has not been mentioned in this
conversation but was made note during
the hearing if you look at the
definitions in line 26 to 27 on the
first page of the amendment in this
chapter public school student means any
child enrolled in a New Hampshire or
public or chartered Public School
now it doesn't say K through 12 school
and we do have public universities in
the states such as UNH and the
university system and there's nothing in
this bill to believe that those students
attending those school would be Exempted
so some of these rights were recognizing
the rights of adults because the
majority of college students are not of
minor age and the distinction is not
made and it's ambiguous as worded
further discussion from the committee
representative thank you Mr chair I also
see this as a violation of natural
rights because the students don't have
the right to choose what type of
education they are pursuing when they're
under the age of 18
and I would argue over the age of 18
depending on who's paying for it
and that children have the right and
protection of their from their parents
and when it comes to their health
education and Welfare and if the parents
have a duty to that the students have a
duty to follow what their parents tell
them until they are emancipated from
further discussion from the committee
not seeing any discussion uh so we have
Amendment zero two three two H uh with a
motion for OTP in front of us Madam
clerk would you please call the roll
Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative blackis no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
Representative cortiello no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
no
10 years 10 A's
okay Sr are there any further emotions
on the original motion
please
okay we have a request for the original
motion which is OTP without Amendment
a made by represent Tanner and separate
second by represent luno no Myler Myler
just go right to about yeah further
discussion
[Music]
that there's uh represent Tanner moved
ought to pass
with represent miles second again
okay when you're ready Madam Clerk
Vice chairman cordelli no
representative Lucas no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
Representative cortiello no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner
representative luno yes representative
Ellison representative Wilcock
representative Hall yes
representative Balboni yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
no
so we have at this point no
recommendation
10 10.
any further recommendations
not seeing so uh
who will be writing the uh pardon me
okay representative Tanner do you want
it to be OTP or otpa
well I'm gonna have to put the
instruments
in McDonald's
okay good got it okay with that we're
going to be going on to the next item on
our docket for today which is the first
item okay uh cacr7 relating to use some
money raised by taxation for Education
providing that money raised by taxation
maybe apply for the use of religious
represent cordelli recognized for
emotion
oh
thank you I would like to move out to
pass on cacr7 I'll second that okay
representative seconds
you got that okay good uh represent
cordelli thank you
um
we have a uh history in New Hampshire as
in other states of removing obsolete
provisions of our constitution
um I'll Point specifically to 1968 and
1980 where three Provisions were removed
um I'll go back to the
edition of the Blaine amendment to our
constitution in 1877
just prior to that in 1906 excuse me
1868.
um in the Hale versus Everett New
Hampshire Supreme Court case
um there had been in statute for years
the requirement that elected officials
um in 19 in 1868 the Supreme Court said
that that was a dead letter
and remove and it should be removed from
the Constitution a dead letter as
defined in the legal dictionary is a
statute that is no longer enforced but
has not been formally repealed
and added in the US makes me
u.slegal.com it cannot be enforced
in 1877
that provision for Protestant religion
of elected officials was removed
at the same time the Blaine amendment
was was added by the voters and as we've
talked about in the past it was a
reaction to what was going on in the
time
um
with the know-nothing party the
predecessors to the Ku Klux Klan
Church burnings and an anti-catholic and
anti-jewish movement in the country to
keep the schools as Protestant
institutions
um
it was suggested at the time that they
removed the
um Protestant elected officials
provision but added the blame Amendment
um so that Catholics who now were going
to be allowed into office would not be
able to use their position to provide
um we've heard
that um
the Supreme Court decisions were narrow
rulings
that is not the case the rulings in
multiple
cases has been very Broad and
substantive substantial when it comes to
school choice
some of the initial cases were different
than our education Freedom accounts for
instance the zelman versus Simmons
Harris case was a uh excuse me in Ohio
Voucher Program now we don't have
vouchers we all know in New Hampshire
but this was a voucher case and the
opinion of the case
said excuse me sorry Luna don't don't
cast what okay let's let's not have any
sideways discussions here represent
cordelli has the floor
um the opinion stated
I'm putting words in my own mouth at the
moment uh the Ohio program permits such
individuals to exercise genuine Choice
among options public and private secular
and religious the program is therefore a
program of true private Choice as stated
in the Supreme Court decision in Trinity
Lutheran versus Comer case
um just chief justice Roberts wrote
exclusion of Trinity Lutheran from a
public benefit for which it is otherwise
qualified solely because it is a church
is odious odious to our constitution all
the same and cannot stand
in the
Espinoza versus Montana Department of
just from uh three years ago
it
was stated by Justice Alito
that if a state decides to fund private
education institutions it cannot
discriminate against parents who choose
to send their children to religious
schools
Justice Roberts added we have repeatedly
held that The Establishment Clause is
not offended when religious observers
and organizations benefit from neutral
government programs
just last year Maine Carson versus Macon
Justice Roberts reiterated what he had
written in the 2020 case a state need
not subsidize private education but once
the state decides to do so it cannot
disqualify private schools solely
because they are religious
a neutral benefit program which public
in which public funds flow to the
religious organizations through the
independent choice of private benefit
recipients private benefit recipients
it's no longer public money it's private
benefit recipients does not offend The
Establishment Clause
I would offer that
the Blaine Amendment Article 2 Section
it is a remnant of bigotry it is a stain
on our constitution is no longer
enforceable based on multiple U.S
Supreme Court decisions and needs to be
removed and we need to send it to the
thank you
further discussion
yes represent whitcock
thank you chairman
um
I'm not going to get into the history of
rather than cordelli but I will want to
get in the current times I know we
always hear what our constituents say
our constituents say our constituents
say I'm not sure what you guys are
hearing I'll tell you one thing I hear
the one thing I hear from my
constituents and the people uh that talk
to me there are a few besides Alpha
is is that
I don't want my tax dollar going really
to school
that's right here it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter if it goes through a
private independent resource and passes
its way through the dollar no matter how
it gets there my public taxes I do not
want to sponsor someone's going to the
school so let's
it's a clue I'm just going to tell you
that's my opinion brought forth by my
constituents and I want to make it
public here today thank you further
discussion representative
mm-hmm thank you Mr chair
it's interesting that the sites that
representative cordelli made on some of
these uh Supreme Court decisions is
interesting because
the Lutheran case was basically targeted
for a playground
not school education
the Espinoza case came out of a tax
credit program very similar to what we
have in this state from a standpoint
who's been made very clear in this
committee that tax credits are not
public Monies
very similar to this and that's what
Espinoza was about
in the main case was very similar to
what we had in the Croydon case in this
stage where you had a school that only
went up I'm not sure if like the sixth
grade and they wanted to send kids out
of the school to another to another
school and they provided uh public
monies for that tuition
the other issue that hasn't been
mentioned in this conversation
and I'd like to read this to the
committee
this comes out of the Constitution part
one article 6.
and I quote
no person shall ever be compelled to pay
towards the support of schools of any
sect or denomination
1784.
so as far as I'm concerned uh
notwithstanding the arguments about
religion Etc and the blame Amendment
Constitution is very clear about how
money should be spent and should not go
towards a sect or a denomination
so I I'm absolutely going to post this
uh OTP thank you
thank you Mr chair first I I want to
speak to the the last item that was just
brought up because I do think it's an
important item it's a separate Clause
within the state constitution of New
Hampshire and it is admittedly a
complicating Factor when we look at all
this but let's be clear
it is not just complicating for
Religious Education because the Supreme
Court has ruled that secular humanism is
a religion the Supreme Court has also
ruled that because education cannot
possibly be Viewpoint Mutual you cannot
possibly remove secular
humanism and what is taught in schools
from that milou of religiosity
therefore when the secular Public
Schools took over from the church
education as they did in the late 1800s
in New Hampshire it wasn't actually
transferring from a religious based
worldview to a Viewpoint neutral world
view it was transferring it from one
Viewpoint to another Viewpoint so that
would actually complicate not just PRI
uh rather private education but also
public education and we haven't heard a
skoda's decision on that so until we do
I don't think there's any point in
thank you Mr chair to address the
concerns because of part one article 6
of the New Hampshire Constitution
removing the blame amendment in our
constitution would not actually change
the policy regarding funding private
education religious education with the
intent of this bill really is to do is
to remove a stain as representative
cordelli put it on our Constitution that
was anti-immigrant anti-catholic and in
that time anti-immigrant was anti-irish
and we're coming up upon St Patrick's
Day and here we are still arguing if we
should recognize the people in this
country of Irish heritage or immigrants
of any background
thank you representative cordelli uh
thank you
um talking about part one article six
the what's referred to as the compelled
reason Clause
um a number of those States
um and those Court decisions
um that I just referenced um had similar
uh Clauses in their constitutions and
were referred to
um as being not applicable by the
Supreme Court but just let me go back to
um
1784 when this language was adopted
religious worship was supported by town
taxes that's what this was about
most of those churches were
congregational churches
in 1791 the act for regulating towns and
choice of town officers passed and it
included authorizing Town voters to
collect taxes to support the local
Ministry
so that's what the compelled reason
Clause is talking about to having the
government collect taxes to give to
churches
towns were enforcing that to vary in
degrees and that Act was repealed in
1819 as more faiths were coming into the
country and there was more opposition to
favoring one religion
primarily the Congregational Church
with tax dollars that's what the
compelled reason Clause article part 1
representative cordiello do you have
here you're all set now
further discussion representative
Belcher yes I would just say because I I
have received emails from constituents
and other people suggesting they don't
want their money going to Religious
Education I understand the viewpoint
the last point I want to make on this is
you don't have to like what's happening
right here because Supreme Court has
ruled on this
but I think it's important to note that
if we vote against it as a house we are
in fact sending a signal to the federal
yeah representative Tanner
um could you give me the reference to
the Supreme Court decision that said
that secular humanism is a religion
I can certainly get that to you
not seeing any uh we're ready to go
ahead then we are we have a motion of
OTP on the Constitutional Amendment
concurrent resolution number seven the
use of money raised by taxation for
education
okay providing raise right taxation may
be applied for the use of religious
educational institutions
uh Madam clerk would you please Mr
chairman yes just a quick question of
the chair
um uh this first time that that that
I've uh been in a committee where we're
voting taking your committee making a
committee recommendation on a
constitutional amendment and I was just
wondering if you could explain the
process in committee on the floor and
afterwards uh uh where something like
this goes
well where this will go is I'm talking
about in terms of vote splits okay
so in terms of what we do is we take
action at this this meeting right here
whether it's up or down
and then the simple majority is simple
majority right here but that's not the
case on the house floor when it gets
if it were to achieve three-fifths yes
that goes over there for the same thing
and and then it does not have to go to
the governor's office right right
absolutely it goes on to a ballot right
that's right and then the voters have to
decide the issue by uh super majority by
a super majority I think it's two-thirds
vote that's the super majority right
there from the voters so so thank you Mr
chair because I just think that's a very
interesting
um uh you know uh type thing because
it's not like our usual Bill process
absolutely and it's it's like that
intentionally here we're talking about
the Constitution
and so that's why it takes this type of
action at various levels so this is the
the one level where it's just you know a
majority great thank you very much so
with that uh Madam clerk are you ready
to call the roll yeah
Vice chairman cordelli yes
excuse me I'm sorry yes
representative four yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Peter now yes representative cortielo
yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no representative Luna no
representative Ellison no representative
Wilcox representative Hall no
representative Balboni no Representative
cascadden no representative Damon no
chairman left yes 10 years 10 days
motion
you have a motion represent Myler uh yes
I moved Ito second
represent Tanner seconds representative
represent Myler
no we've had enough conversation
conversation okay rep San Tanner same
thing
okay when you're ready Madam Clerk
the motion is itl
on cacr 7.
Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative no representative Ford oh
representative Belcher no representative
dry no representative McDonnell no
representative Noble
now representative Peter no no
representative Coors yellow no
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Wilcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadin yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
no
no further emotions of any kind not
seeing that so uh who will be writing
the your report uh representative
ought to pass yeah you'll be doing that
okay we're gonna take about a five
minute break here for folks if you have
to go to the washroom of that and then
we're going to come back and go to noon
yes if I made just for the record and
provide that information the Scottish
case I referenced was torcasso versus
Watkins 1961 has been upheld uh
similarly rulings by federal courts
multiple times since then
uh thank you Mr chairman and I call on
the chairman for a motion
thank you very much representative
cardelli I'd like to put forth the
by representative Ford
uh
back to the chairman yes and so I'd like
to End discussion here I'd also like to
present uh
amendment0839h which I believe has been
passed around to everybody and I'll I
will walk folks through that uh
uh Amendment uh so I'd first like to put
the uh the motion forward for OTP on the
second second corruption or forward
again thank you okay walking through
this the area which the bill had is it
highlighted there on lines 11 through uh
14.
and what this does is that we have a
number of smaller schools in this state
that tuition their students primarily
secondary students but many of them some
also go tuition from grades four five
six seven right up through grade 12.
and what we've done in statutory law
we've allowed these local school board
to approve the school that they're
sending these students to
and they then uh have to ensure in their
their programming that they're going to
provide the services that are necessary
for students from everything from
special education through all those
components and aspects of the adequate
many of these schools have contracts
which they've entered into with a
receiving school they may have as many
as three or four different contracts and
the school district I'm talking about is
there are several of them in my district
I'll talk about one of them and I've
done it before many times here is the
small village at Piermont which is a K-8
school roughly around 60 kids
and they have contracts with Woodsville
High School which is in Haverhill
they have contracts with Oxbow High
School which is in Bradford Vermont
they have contracts with Rivendell which
is an interstate School District which
is fairly Vermont and Orford New
Hampshire
Corinth gets involved with that somewhat
as well in Vermont they have contracts
there with Thetford Academy also in
Vermont and prior years they've had them
with mescoma as well dipping down into
the Hanover area
these contracts are such that they
negotiate them and there's a language
that's put together and what happens as
these contracts and years move forward
the other point I want to mention is how
does the town of Piermont then decide
um what their how much money they're
going to spend they take the tuition
costs for Woodsville High School
for Oxbow High School in Bradford
Vermont and they take the cost to
sending a kid to Rivendell which is down
the river in Orford the average that
cost
and then they add on a fudge factor of
18 on top of that
so that close to around twenty thousand
dollars for tuition today so they look
at their schools and all those schools
fall within that range and there are
like four kids still going to St
Johnsbury Academy which they also
tuition to and their tuition went up
about a thousand dollars on top of
uh where we have the cap
and the parents are now saying well my
child is there can they continue to go
to school there yes they continue to go
there are they going to be charged that
difference though after this year is
over and that school board's been
hassling that issue out and and then as
a result of that some of the parents are
saying may I pay the difference
if I opt to go to the academy which is
an independent school it's approved by
Department of Education in Vermont and
by the commissioner of Education wrote a
letter for that that was back in when
Virginia Barry did it and it's an
approved School ass is uh Freiburg
Academy over in Maine so we've been
sending kids that direction but now
they're saying look the cap the cost is
above the cap which we have here and
parents back to what I said are saying
so they are hassling right now they've
been told by various attorneys different
stories
it's a confusing issue right now because
this is also likened to landaf which is
a community which I also have which is a
small k-3 school they call it the blue
School up in land app and they tuition
their kids to Lisbon but they also allow
high school kids based upon what the
parent would like to do some are going
over to profile which is over to the
west of it and and one child even goes
to St Johnsbury Academy but they're
paying for it they're paying for
regardless what that tuition is land
that's paying for that additional cost
Paramount is in a situation right now
where their operating budget projected
for next year is 22 percent higher than
it was last year they've received
several of these cat Aid type students
and it's just thrown that whole budget
out of whack so they're looking how can
we keep our budget down where we can not
nail our people with property taxes
anymore so what this bill does
it has a sense here to enroll a child in
a tuition School approved by the local
school board whose tuition cost is above
the district's established tuition cost
per pupil
as determined and approved by the board
the local board may require may require
the parent to pay the tuition cost
difference
now this is the new part in this as long
as at least one option one of those
schools a b c d whatever it might be
at least one option does not require
additional tuition payment from the
parent so they're looking for a a school
in which they can send their kids to
that is not going to cost a parent any
money at all
that might be in the case where I am it
might be Oxbow it may be Rivendell it
may be Thetford Academy but would not be
St Johnsbury Academy seeing that the
parent would you know somebody's gonna
have to pay that difference and so what
we're trying to do is work around find
out what is you know permissible this
language which we have in front of us
today was written uh just yesterday by
the AG's office they feel that this is
pretty you know secure in fact that we
are providing districts the option
to send them to a school and for example
they are providing paramounts providing
that Transportation even though they
don't have to because it's high school
they're too Oxbow which is Bradford
Vermont and Rivendell they connect buses
between the town lines so and the
Woodsville as well so all that is
available but there are some parents
that want to continue their kids to go
to the academy so this is what this is
trying to do so uh
that's all I have at this time
representative cordelli
uh thank you anything from the uh
secondary of the motion representative
fort
no nothing improved further discussion
representative miler well thank you Mr
chair so let's just clarify this so as
I'm reading this it basically says that
um prior to
a parent having to pay a
an additional tuition to a school of
their choice
that there is an anchor school I'll use
that term since we used that earlier
today now with Croydon yes there is an
anchor school that is available in this
case we're basically talking I would
assume either middle school or a high
school
that anchor school would be an option
for per for parents to choose where they
would not have to pay any traditional
any tuition additional tuition is that
correct that is correct okay thank you
very much
for the discussion of Representative
luno thank you very much Mr chair so
um would um
if uh if the local school board were to
approve
right approved by the local childhood
tuition School approved by the local
school board so if the if the local
school board were to approve a private
school I didn't pick any of them
um uh you know St Paul's is right here
in Concordia
yeah yeah any of those
um then um then then what am I correct
then what what uh If This Were law this
would allow the um uh the the student to
take whatever the of the the approved
budget
um per pupil
um tuition
cost
determined by the school board and use
that to pay tuition at Kua or St Paul's
or well I think can I clarify it just to
make sure we're absolute the the school
that the student's going to go to has to
be approved
by the local board yeah and if the local
board may say uh we'll pay it
they would pay that difference or they
may require the parent so that's a
decision that local policy is going to
have to decide that and how they're
going to do that okay so so further
further clarification then to make sure
I'm understanding that the the the local
board
um could say all right we will pay the
full used tax dollars to pay the full
Kua tuition or the full St Paul's
tuition or will pay up to what we um
what we pay to tuition our students to
let's say Newport High School or
something like that say it was twenty
thousand dollars we'll uh we'll pay up
to 20 grand and we'll approve KOA in St
Paul's and parents your your um it's up
to you to pay the remaining you know 70
grand 60 60 000 or whatever it is to to
go there is is
the basic concept or the school board
can pay the whole toll free
you just yeah yeah if they want to you
know of course you know we've had
situations where in a community south of
Orford where we had Parents saying well
I want my student to go to St J Academy
well the tuition rate to Saint J at that
point in time was around sixteen
thousand dollars but if you go as a
boarding student you're going to be
paying seventy thousand dollars of
course that particular Community said
absolutely not we're not doing that we
have a contract with them for tuition
not board so we're not going that route
I don't know if you're thinking of are
we going to end up having to pay for
board uh no and we're not going to get
in the business of trying to decide
we're going to just select this private
school as that's where all our kids are
going to go and we'll pay the difference
this is trying to support uh options but
the the options are not necessarily
private schools most of the situation
not the state is dealing with Public
Schools where there's you know they have
different agreements throughout the
state this is widely accepted throughout
the state however it's being done very
quietly and now the attorneys are saying
well you can't do that because you're
you're discriminating against the parent
that doesn't have the money to send the
child to school X well let me take can I
take it a little further the follow-up
thank you thank you so so
um let's say uh I live in I live in
Hopkinton I do live in Hopkinton and uh
obviously I was I was chair of the
school board for a lot of years and our
kids
um went uh went through the Hopkins
school district but let's say
um let's say I'm a parent in Hopkinton
and I'm and I'm currently um sending my
my child to Saint Paul's and I'm paying
full Freight tuition at St Paul's and I
I I I don't know what it is now would
seventy five thousand dollars a year be
out of the out of the realm so I'm
paying seventy five thousand dollars a
year and um and they're in um St Paul's
I think calls their kids like fourth
fifth and sixth formers but but I'll
just go with the the sophomore junior
um um uh type of nomenclature so let's
say my son's a junior
um or my child's a junior at St Paul's
I'm spending 75 000 a year
um uh I could go to my school board and
um and say hey could you put Saint
Paul's on the list and then uh send me a
check for um for twenty thousand dollars
and uh and I can use that to pay my
tuition how how would If This Were law
How would how would I mean is is that
what one of the intents of I mean
something that could happen if this were
a while
it has to be approved by the locals I'm
saying that so I go to I go to the
school board and I say hey won't you
would you approve St Paul's I mean don't
we want our kids to get St Paul's it's
not that easy you have to your of course
your agreements and your money is
already in the year your operating
budget that you have so that's been done
based prior to this so but it could
happen right
I mean it's basically opening the door
if there is a community that's out there
that will send the kids to holderness
and pay for holderness and room and
board I'd be glad to send my grandkids
there uh so I'll just tell me where that
Community is but I do not think that
that's going to be the case here I think
what we're trying to do is uh maintain
situations like we've had in the past
with Freiburg Academy where kids from
the Conway are have gone that way or in
where I am where they uh have the the
choice of various schools and that
choice in the rural areas is very very
important we don't have Charter Schools
other than the one that's a wonderful
one up in Littleton but there's only one
or two seats available and that from the
area where I live for the you know that
Regional there's a lot of folks living
so we we also are residing and we have
but St J Academy offers things that
um uh you won't find at Oxbow you won't
find at Rivendell you won't find it
Woods still and if you want a fine
theater program you probably would want
to go to Oxbow that's or in Bradford
Vermont if you want to have a division
four basketball championship you know
you go to Woodsville which they just won
the other day if you want to have a a
program that's really excellent in other
aspects like Rivendell has you would go
that direction it provides those options
for for it's it's a it's a choice
program but through two-ish has nothing
new vouchers has nothing to do with any
of that this is the traditional way
no no thank you thank you I appreciate
that Mr chair but but uh but don't
um families and students already have
those options I mean I hear from from
families in Hopkinton that they move to
Hopkinton because of the schools and um
so I mean don't those don't those
options already exist
they do that's why people from for
example the area around Hanover and
Lebanon that are working there at
Dartmouth Hitchcock choose to live in
paramount because it's right on the
interstate highway there and they can
zap down in 30 minutes and be down and
have her but they also know by coming
there I'm going to have the opportunity
to have my child go to either Thetford
Academy or a saint Jay or all these
other schools that's that's the draw for
Piermont right now
um now when when Saint Jay jumped their
their tuition by a thousand dollars
which you know I perhaps if you did the
calculation if they changed that
percentage maybe 19 then you would have
that still in the cards but we have
students attending there and that
tuition has occurred and now as a
sophomore you might end up having to go
somewhere else because it's above the
cap
and in that you know once it's above the
cap then unless the parent can pay that
difference and the pyrmont's not willing
to pay that difference you're going to
have kids having to opt somewhere else
to go to school
thank you
um I'm going to ask this question
because I live in an SAU and the
children in my community we only serve
up to eighth grade and then we have an
agreement with bources high school and
that's where we send our children so I'm
trying to understand how this would
affect my district
um right now they only have one school
choice and that's Portsmouth if
something like this gets passed wouldn't
that encourage
families in in my district and a lot of
them do as choose private school at that
point and send their kids to Phillips
Exeter and right now it's not approved
by our board as you're saying but
wouldn't that put pressure on the school
board at some point if we this law is
passed to have people come to our board
and maybe take legal action to have us
approve that school and if that's the
case then our um like our
we the tuition price that we pay for
prices of high school would actually
increase our budget for the number of
schools so they're we're not currently
paying for it it wouldn't change the
costs above what you're paying for a
tuition to the current school that
you're using
that would be your anchor school now if
another person came and said I'd like to
go over here to this one first of all
the board would have to approve if they
don't approve it and there's no legal
action you can take because the board's
responsible for providing an adequate
opportunity for an adequate education
for a student we provide that they're
going to this present High School
uh but if they wanted to get in the
option they could have a contract an
agreement with the other school and they
would have to settle on what the tuition
rate's going to be uh most likely they
wouldn't increase any higher than what
they you're presently paying it's not
going to jump their budget
follow yes thank you
um so so what I guess what I'm trying to
say is there's quite a number of schools
in our community of students in our
community they are currently going to
private schools and we're not paying for
so what would happen is our budgets
would increase
substantially if if if something went
through and and that choice was made
that we were going to provide that so
say we're paying twenty thousand dollars
to support since high school per student
and all of a sudden 10 more students
that are currently in private school
decide that they want that option then
that increases our budget
substantially those students in the
other schools are not part of your adma
right now they may be part of your admr
but they're not you're once they go
there they're part of your adma and you
are receiving monies for those students
too but it would be the same I doubt
very seriously the scenario you're
trying to refer what would occur
I can't see that happening thank you
uh represent Tanner
thank you
um
when the bill came uh before us before
about allowing schools that
communities that had schools to a
certain uh level and then tuition to
other schools and we made the provision
now that's in in law and I actually
voted for it where the school board has
to approve
um the schools that that they're
choosing
at that time I was representing Croydon
as one of my floaterials and what
happened consequently in Croydon in case
you didn't hear is that they cut the
budget okay they cut the budget in half
and they cut it so low that it was much
lower than what the tuition rate was for
the nearby public school Newport School
the only option students had or parents
had to send their students to a school
board approved School
was a school that was a private school
that had substantially less tuition than
the public school
If the parents wanted to send their kids
to the public school and many of them
had now Croydon only goes to fourth
grade so they there were students that
had been in the Newport public school
you know for six seven years uh going
through a program going through Career
Technical Ed that they had at the school
uh participating on the football team
whatever uh now had to pay the money
over and above what the school board had
said as their top and we know that other
school boards are set in caps you you
said that yourself
so I'm asking what in this I I feel like
this bill is just going to throw the
door wide open
um for abuses like this or the abuses
that representative alboni spoke of I
mean one of the things we found with the
efas was that the vast majority of
people that took the advantage of the
vouchers were people who were already
sending their kids to private or
parochial schools and it in fact
increased what the state's um
burden was tax burden or and essentially
through the resources of taxpayers at
some level uh began so I'm just I'm
really afraid to to
um open the door to this I feel like
it's opening Pandora's door to either go
uh representative balboni's way or
representative Damon's way from Croydon
so it right now
I I assume the reason we have to have
that is that doing that is illegal
through the AG's office
and and you said it was a gray area so
I'm assuming the reason we have this is
to codify it so that there's no no gray
area left that's what we're trying to do
is codify this this is this is occurring
throughout the state and when you talk
about Croydon yeah you you've tuition
before with Newport you've tuition with
centipede
you've tuitioned with Kua you have
tuition with the Montessori School
all those options have been available
and but it's up to your local board to
make that decision uh this is not going
to change the cost of doing business uh
at all beyond what the cost is for that
anchor school we'll call it the anchor
School whatever that tuition rate is
that's what you're going to be paying
for your students and in your
responsible for all students basically
living in your District if somebody
wants to come back to public school I'd
welcome they'll come back to Public
Schools it does when we say when when
you give that little explanation and I
look at what has happened in Croydon
is there a provision in there that that
at least one of the schools that has to
be fully paid for so that the student
gets a free and adequate public
it has to be a school that's approved by
your local board and what we have here
is that there has to be at least one
school that provides the options that
you're looking for
I can't support this unless we have
specifically in there based on my
personal experience and the experience
of the citizens of Croydon
that it be that the tuition can be no
lower than at least
an option for a public school that
provides a free and adequate education
be it the public charter school or the
public school
thank you
following up on representative Tanner's
discussion around Croydon which is where
I live
but also noting that
there are many towns including at least
two three others in my district that
this applies to so I think this is a
it's a pretty substantive bill in terms
of the number of communities and towns
I do not read this to say that
the town would be obligated
for the school that is the anchor school
to be a public school
and that does concern me
I'm going to follow chairman lad's
example and use a specific example so
according has K to four
many of our fifth through 8th graders go
to the Montessori School in Newport
which is a wonderful School wonderful
education well respected
it is less than ten thousand dollars
tuition per year
the kids who don't go there mostly go to
Newports some go to Summit
and either of those schools it's now in
the ballpark of nineteen twenty thousand
dollars a year the way I read this bill
the town of Croydon could decide that
the anchor school for fifth to 8th
graders because the Montessori ends at
eighth grade
Montessori school and there is no option
for parents to go to public schools
without me and they'd be paying you ever
take ten thousand dollars out of pocket
per student per year
I totally agree that it needs to specify
that there is a public school option
that the
cap is based on
um
so Interruption lead
if you read on line five which is
already current law
if there is no public school for the
child's grade in the residential
district the school board May contract
with another Public School in another
school district or with any private
school that has been approved as a
tuition School tuition program by the
school board
so that is existing when you're talking
about Santa Fe Sunapee said we're going
to take this kid but not that kid
they were very specific on who was going
to go to their school new part was your
your your anchor school and so a student
there would definitely have the ability
to go and receive the an opportunity for
an adequate education for all the grades
are in at Newport
they may not have received that in some
other school but those were our options
and the option here is that you know if
you wanted that you would send them the
Newport the same thing here if you want
the option in in for example uh Piermont
you have the option of sending them
either to Rivendell to Woodsville or to
Oxbow or up to the time that the tuition
cap was increased and it went a little
bit over and thank goodness the
Headmaster up at St J Academy and when I
worked with them said we will try to
work with your students that are
currently involved and and the board did
work with them on that but uh but
because it's a little higher the parents
are not saying can we continue to have
our students you know go there some of
it as a result of like and landf where
they go to profile they only go there
because the The Adult and Family works
there and it makes it easier on the
parent
so uh I can't understand why there is an
issue with this this is occurring
basically in many school districts
around the state right now and it's uh
one which is in the best interest of of
the student well
thank you Mr chair both Mr chairs
um
understand what you read that is the
current law and I agree that this is
happening already in a lot of
um
schools towns however
what is also happening right now again
using the Croydon example
is that our current School Board does
not want to pay what Newport is charging
somebody's actually less than Newport
now
and so they are trying to make it so
that
they will cap tuition at a level that
I don't see how this bill addresses that
because in the new part
the line 13 to 15. it does not specify
Public School
so it could be a private school
that would be the town's anchor school
yes but that is current law
the private school is in current law
here and the reference to Croydon
it says with any private school that has
been approved as a school tuition
program the local board has the
responsibility to ensure that every
student they have has an opportunity to
an adequate education and that would be
one of the criteria that they'd have to
do if that private school were the only
anchor or the only school they had an
agreement with they would have to
provide the opportunity for an adequate
education and of course they would have
to do it at the amount of money that the
local board was going to approve if not
the local board as a case through sex or
K-8 would have to seek a high school a
public school or another school in the
state which would meet what they're
trying to do using the issue of Croydon
I can't accept what that Croydon board
did cutting the budget in half
from one point what eight million
dollars to less than half of that that
is an issue that could have been brought
up and and litigation brought forward
saying you're not providing an
opportunity for an adequate education
I'm sure there are people going down
that road that situation occurred on
Croydon I can't
I can't tell you another school school
district in the state that's done that
Croydon went off the deep edge
and so let's not compare this to Croydon
let's compare it to what's going on
through all these other schools that
half the tuition because they just don't
have the grades and levels there and
they have to take either near school or
the nearest several schools to get in
and offer parents what they're looking
for in the what for the programming as
long as one of those schools is an
anchor school fine the president
if you
if nothing change
and what the current block is
how would this change
well right now we don't have it
happening right here but on any given
day there might be four different
attorneys sitting out here in the
audience
and we get four different answers
um at least
and and what you have if you have
attorneys giving advice counsel legal
counsel to the local board the local
board always has some attorney in the
background giving them advice
the advice from this attorney may be you
can't do that because you're
discriminating against a child to
parents that can't afford to do this
um others are saying well you are
providing the opportunity for that
student to go to school a which is the
anchor school which has all the things
the child needs special education
Etc so
um but you have other districts saying
you just can't do this because we don't
think it's it's above the table so what
we have now is we have different towns
doing different things and we're trying
to legalize what's doing here by Statute
and saying you may re you may pay it
yourself School District the difference
or you may ask the parent to pay the
difference but you must provide an
alternative situation option for the
parent where they want to have this
education and they don't have to pay a
dime
representative
let me um go to representative dry who
has a question for uh I think
I'm sorry
that's right thank you
um there are two
private high schools that are serving as
public high schools right now Co Brown
and Pinkerton Academy and there is no
Independent Schools yeah Independent
Schools so they are not Public Schools
is that correct so though but those are
the high school for those their
governance is different than a school
district okay so so would they fit
under the definition we're trying to
expand it to that they needed to have a
public anchor School
for these towns wouldn't be meeting that
go ahead representative I think I
believe that some time ago
both uh Cole Brown and uh Pinkerton
work by the labor board where they were
determined to be public schools because
they are basically funded through public
dollars they may have an academy there
used to be a series of academies across
the state and over the years that the
term Academy was dropped but the labor
board I think it was
uh late 80s uh there was a question
about the collective bargaining and
whether or not they could be organized
and it was determined that they could be
organized because they are in fact
public entities paid through public
money so even though they may have an
academy at the end of it they are in
fact Public Schools
well
everybody just so you get some
clarification on that
St Johnsbury Academy and Pinkerton
Academy are similar Independent Schools
which they do not have a school board
they have trustees which are appointed
and elected by the trustees
they do receive public dollars via the
tuition
in the case of Saint Johnsbury Academy
it's a school roughly around thousand
kids which 240 come from all over the
world and they pay the tuition and board
the other students come from a lot of
most
a huge number come from New Hampshire
from Monroe from Littleton from Bath
from Paramount from lime
they come from down from Quebec to go to
Saint J they come from as far over as
Montpelier
and these students come in the 600 plus
of them close to 700 our day students
and that's very similar St Johnsbury uh
with the New England Association of
schools and colleges they're the ones
that go down in the credit Pinkerton and
Pinkerton people come up and accredited
Saint J
it's very closely aligned the two
schools
representative Woodcock back to you
Pinkerton also has a contract with
chester for all of its to secondary
thank you Mr chair I would ask if um
representative Milo would allow for a
would you like to break now uh pursue
with the conversation yes were there any
comments further before representative
Tanner
like to know the difference between
a private school
a school for tuition and a public school
in terms of what their requirements are
by the state to provide
thank you any further comment before we
caucus can I get an answer to that
both the schools we're talking about
here Pinkerton and Saint J are approved
by the Departments of Education
they're also accredited through the same
accrediting organization they provide
all the services that you would provide
at Newport right those two schools but a
school that's tagged as a tuition a
school for tuition purposes what is the
minimum standards for that school is
that spelled out in statute under the
tuition program which we have that
that's approved by the local board
that's a local decision
whether they're adequate or not whether
they're aren't they approved by the
State Board of Education for tuition
purposes and if so it was my
understanding that there there are
requirements which they're required to
have if you look in the statute you're
going to see they have to have certain
requirements but they are only approved
by the local board as a tuition School
as a tuition school okay the state
report doesn't certify them
or doesn't uh
doesn't say that they are acceptable as
a tuition school right representative
pedernal
well
I have
the RSA underneath this one which is
193.37 and they have the school has to
be approved as a tuition school program
which means the school has been approved
and contracted by the school board and
then it goes on a private school that
receives tuition program students shall
and then there's a whole list of
requirements under that yeah that we put
depends
I apologize uh Becky Wilson director of
governmental relations for the New
Hampshire school boards Association and
I apologize because I do not have a copy
of this amendment in front of me I
haven't read it so I'm a little bit
speaking off the cuff but I feel like
the intent of this original bill has
somehow got lost in the thank you so
much representative
in the translation of this conversation
so now even I'm confused so I wanted to
try to just I guess put some context
around what I thought the original
intention was and then try to weave in
what I think some of the questions are
about this bill so I will use Candia as
an example for
um as candy is a K-8 school district
they have tuition agreements with
Pinkerton Academy Raymond High School
Central High School in Manchester in
Memorial and Manchester all of the those
four high schools the school board has a
written tuition agreement with each of
those high schools the tuition at each
of those high schools in those
Agreements are different amounts of
money
so the cost to go to Pinkerton that the
Candia School District would pay to
Pinkerton is a different amount than
what the Candia School District would
pay to Raymond High School if a student
chooses to go to Raymond however all
four of those Agreements are entered
into between the receiving schools and
the Candia School District so if I'm a
student in Candia and I'm done with
eighth grade and I choose to go to
Pinkerton Academy that cost x amount of
dollars
and then I'm a student who wants to go
to Raymond that costs a different amount
and Central costs a different amount and
Memorial costs a different amount so
when I'm a district administrator trying
to budget for the next however many
years I'm calculating my tuition line
item based off of how many kids I think
I have going to Pinkerton because I'm
still as candy I'm responsible for those
students
I'm projecting out how much I think that
cost is going to be for the next four
years for the students that we have at
the time
my original understanding of this bill
was that if I'm a candy student who's
currently going to Raymond and I decide
my sophomore year I now want to go to
Pinkerton I have that option as a Candia
student however I've been budgeted at
the Raymond amount
so now if pinkerton's tuition agreement
that we have is more money my
understanding of what I thought this
bill was was that the district could not
say to the parent
hey your kid cost x amount of dollars
and that's what I've planned for now you
want to go to Pinkerton that's on you
the difference between whatever Raymond
was and Pinkerton
that the intent of this bill was that
districts could then say okay we
understand that you want to switch it up
for whatever the reasons are and we will
absorb that cost because these are all
tuition agreements that we have offered
to all Candia students
I don't I don't I understand the concern
I think listening to the conversation
that may be the way this is worded
would change that intent
and I I think from what I've heard going
around in the last few minutes
the question would be you couldn't say
to the parent
there's no option for your kid to stay
at Raymond or there's no option for your
kid to access any of these because they
all cost more money and so therefore
we're not going to let your child go to
any of these and you can't take the I
don't believe take the money as a parent
that I had going to Raymond and then
just
use it as a voucher to go to any other
school these would not be individual
student agreements these are tuition
agreements that the school board is
entering into with other schools and in
order to be an approved program by the
local school board the school board is
accepting responsibility and has the
obligation to ensure that those students
are getting a free appropriate public
education at all of the programs that
they approve you can't approve a program
that doesn't meet the minimum standards
as a school board you can't approve
um you know some private school that
doesn't
agree to meet all of the federal
obligations that your end State
obligations that as a school board
you're mandated to provide to your
students
so I don't know that that really clears
up the concerns that are floating around
about the amendment because I don't I
haven't had time to really process that
but I feel like it's very confusing at
this point what is the intent
representative land that's exactly what
happened with the situation I'm talking
about uh in Paramount
during the pandemic
students in Piermont eighth graders did
not have the opportunity to go visit
these receiving schools they did it
online visitations
so of the four students
three of them you know for Saint Jay
three of them opted to go to Saint J now
one of them decided to go to Bradford
High School over in Vermont Oxbow
got there went through as a freshman
found out this is not what I want or
what I thought and had never had the
opportunity to be there before
came back and said I'd like to go with
the other students which are in my class
from eighth grade to Saint J in the
interim though the contract agreement
with Saint Jay went up
this is where we are we're at the point
now where the Piermont board's saying
well we don't have that we're you know
and we don't know if we can allow you to
pay that 500 or a thousand dollar
difference
and parents saying I will gladly do that
if I can get them going with the other
four three students seeing that there's
transportation we can carpool it'll work
out just fine that is what happened and
that's what we're trying to avoid from
happening again with this this language
here well I appreciate that and I think
I will say though from a school board
perspective when you're entering into a
tuition agreement with another school
for what for these kinds of reasons
there are many times where schools that
you are sending students to that your
tuition and kids to will reuse the
tuition cost
um as part of your agreement it would be
reasonable to add in there that they
can't just switch the cost mid-year or
something like that you know those are
built into your budget you would need to
work that into your contract with this
between the school districts that you
are working with as to how you're going
to handle changes in tuition I mean it's
not uncommon for tuitions to be changed
while you're you know mid-year because
districts again especially if your
tuition to other Public Schools
everyone's doing their budgets in
October if you know you are Central High
School is going to increase their
tuition rate for students coming from
Auburn then they're going to say hey
Auburn we're increasing our tuition
rates next year just a heads up so that
everybody can budget for that for the
upcoming budget it's you know a year two
years ahead but that should be within
your tuition agreement between the
school boards
a local decision of the local school
board to put that in the agreement
rather than I would I would honestly
thank you for the question
representative I would have to go back
and check and see if there is a um
specific statute that outlines what has
to be in your tuition contract I don't
know offhand honestly that's really fair
it would probably know that answer right
off the top of his head but I don't
questions or any other questions from
Becky uh representative
so
um
if if a student wants to go to a school
that's not in a tuition agreement
with a local school district then that's
the school board has no
parent responsibility thank you for the
question it would be the parents
responsibility
if the school has approved programs that
are approved the school district those
are the choices and if a parent would
like to have their child enrolled
somewhere else they can withdraw from
the school district and go and roll
wherever the heck they want to be
accepted no different than any parent
take any money but there's no money
Associated
nor the town to pay for that tuition no
not unless there was some you know very
obscure you know special edition some
other issue that has nothing to do with
tuition programs thanks thank you very
much for your input uh representative
Damon do you have a yes one more
so I'm just and I appreciate your help
I'm just wondering what happens when
a parent
wants their student to go to a school
that is not currently
one of the designated ones that their
town has a contract with
and the parent petitions the school
board to say I want this school approved
this is currently happening in two towns
in my district
um
is there any RSA or other criteria
precedence
Force towns limiting the number of
schools they will approve and contract
with
thank you for the question I don't know
offhand that there is a limit
I do know that any school that the local
school board approved would have to meet
certain criteria because the reason
you're approving these schools is
because you're saying you don't have a
school that meets the minimum standards
or that meets the appropriate you know
guidelines that are mandated upon
schools to be able to provide an option
to all students to have a free
appropriate public education at the
minimum standard so you're saying as a
district we don't have that we're
offering you these other options that do
have that and we're paying the tuition
for that because we don't have it
um so you would have to I think if you
wanted a new school to be approved by
your school board somehow make a case
that you're not offering that through
any other opportunity and most of the
situations that it sounds like you've
been talking about for the last half
hour or so those options exist within
the school district already because
they've already got these other
tuitioned programs that they've agreed
to so you would have to somehow make a
case that those weren't sufficient and
it
I'll never say never on this committee
but it would be very unusual that you
would make a tuition agreement for one
student
as opposed to all of your students as an
option
see these agreements which they have
these contracts
they're very competitive contracts
um if in fact you have a school of 25
kids which are graduating the receiving
School may say well we're going to give
you this rate if you can give us 60 70
or more of these students
the the town like Paramount I'm talking
about and I wrote down on a sheet here
earlier some of the things they look at
when they're approving the the the these
tuition programs they look at the
academic programming they look at the
performance of the outcomes of
achievement of that's receiving school
they look at graduation rates they look
at special education services they look
at co-curricular activities they look at
the issue of Transportation they look at
uh even in in some of them for example
one reason why a lot of the kids in in
Piermont would go to Oxbow is that is
where our Career Technical education
center is located
it's just like the kids in Colebrook you
know they they go across the river to
Canaan or down some go to Brattleboro uh
so and they also look of course at the
tuition costs if they get a big break
that's where they're gonna you know
that's going to be their primary school
and that's what's happening up there
right now where I am there's between
Warren which is in SAU 23 they're trying
to say well we want to send our kids to
Woodsville because they're getting a
better rate and there's others saying ah
no no no we're going to send them the
Rivendell and there's other parents
saying no they're going to go down to
Plymouth and so this is always going to
be the way it is in all these districts
there's going to be a lot coming in from
parents saying here's where I want my
kid to go but the board has
responsibility in writing these
contracts to look at all these issues I
just mentioned along with the costs of
that and that's the bottom line usually
I just have one more question so
um with the tuition agreements that for
example Candia has
there is no out of the schools that
they've identified there's no school
that a parent couldn't send their
student to that wasn't fully covered by
this by the local taxes and and uh you
know our adequate education grants in
other words there would be no school
that they would have to pay
extra money in order to send their
student there
unless there was like a fee for
basketball or something like that right
thank you for the question
to my understanding yes there would be
no
um it's not a tiered option so to speak
it's not like you know you get this
amount of money and you chose this
school but if you don't like you know
that you can't go to one of the other
approved Schools they're all approved
schools and school programs by the local
school board so there should not be any
additional cost and many of these
contracts it is a different tuition cost
for students who are eligible for
special education for example that are
getting services that caught that
tuition cost might cover some of those
things so that cost might be different
but none of that would be shifted back
down onto the family
um and I I you know again I think
the confusion seems to be around the
amendment in terms of what else you
could do with this money other than
you're entering and it's between school
districts and other school districts not
parents and school districts emergency
life catastrophic Aid you mentioned this
The Specialist is the responsibility of
the resident District
regardless what the tuition school is
tuition school is not going to pay for
that it's going to be the sending school
that's that's in statute
thank you very much for your assistance
welcome thank you are there any other
comments um from the uh committee
questions from the committee
if not uh perhaps we can uh look to our
clerk
they wanted the caucus oh I'm sorry yes
um we're gonna caucus for a few minutes
[Laughter]
oh
uh for everyone's uh information
um as soon as we finish with House Bill
275 we'll break for lunch 45 minute
lunch
we hope to put it back here and start at
one o'clock depending upon when this
any further uh discussion from the
committee
yes
see no further discussion on the
amendment
yes
God
for adopting the amendment on HB 275
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Peter now yes
representative courtiello yes
representative Miler no representative
Tanner
no
representative Luna
yeah
I'm so sorry that's okay see we need
lunch right don't we no
um okay so representative Cornell no
representative Tanner
no
Representative luno no representative
Ellison no representative Wilcox
representative hall now representative
Balboni no Representative cascabin no
representative Damon no chairman Ladd
yes
10 years 10 years
so we have a motion on the table of
ought to pass
uh any discussion on that motion
uh see none looks like everyone's ready
for lunch
um Madam chair and Madam Clerk
Vice chairman cordelli
yes
representative blackis yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
paternal yes representative cortiello
yes representative miler you know
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no representative Luna no
representative Ellison oh representative
Wilcox
representative Hall Nell representative
Balboni no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman LED yes
10 years 10 days
like to make a motion for itl
second
by representative luno
a discussion uh representative anything
okay everybody's good ready for the vote
two months Vice chairman cordelli
no
representative Lucas no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative pedernal
no Representative cortielo no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative Wilcox
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
no
10 days 10 days
okay
um looks like we're at uh no
recommendation for House Bill 275.
Tanner will do the um itl and
representative lad will do the
ought to pass thank you very much what
okay yes a point of information for the
committee I have scheduled uh at noon
time here on March 27th that's a Monday
at 10 o'clock the legislative oversight
uh committee for improvement and
assessment
and uh that's at 10 o'clock in the
morning at one o'clock the higher
education study committee will be
meeting uh at one o'clock both of which
the first uh meeting I just mentioned is
on the 27th at 10 o'clock in the morning
that's the legislative oversight
at 10 o'clock
and then and the afternoon at one
o'clock another statutory committee the
higher education study committee will
meet
the pirate
oh wow
um I'd have to go check right now
because we have two senators that that
have changed
uh Ruth Ward's on it I know
um I'm on it
you're on it
um
Oliver Ford's on it I read
no I
I yeah I think that mop was replaced by
Oliver North because uh moffett's no
really
you know I didn't know Ollie Too
over here yeah that's that's bringing
back a lot of the Vietnam stuff and you
know I knew that and I knew the colonel
worked with him okay
um so going on here yeah you don't know
and I don't want to tell anybody either
um HB 349 relative to special purpose
school district for Bridgewater Hebron
and Groton
um so I'm going to hand the gavel over
to uh represent cordelli so I can make a
motion and I'll take it back after I've
you know gone through that
great thank you and uh I'll call on
chairman lad for a motion thank you very
much I'd like to make the motion of OTP
on HB 349.
in a second
second five representative four
discussion from the chairman okay just
for some backgrounds so everybody is
there on the same page as we are I'm
going to just read some background
information for you so that you're aware
of it
uh the Bridgewater Hebron Village
district is a separate political
subdivision created by Statute in 1997
by the general court
and it's comprised of the talents of
Bridgewater and Hebron
this statute authorizes both towns to
build and operate the Bridgewater Hebron
Village School
so they are a
a village
sub subdivision a separate political
subdivision but they're not a school
district but they own their own School
okay going on three elected
Commissioners oversee the school
facility and grounds
The Village District continues to own
debt-free debt free the Bridgewater
Hebron Village School building
surrounding athletic fields and
furnishings
it leases the school to the Newfound
area school district for one dollar per
year
teachers staff and curriculum management
are provided by the Newfound school
Newfound Area School District
the school was built to alleviate
overcrowding in sau4
at a multi-million dollar cost to the
taxpayers of Bridgewater and Hebron back
in 1999.
since then Bridgewater and Hebron are
responsible for the maintenance repair
and Capital Improvements associated with
that facility
Bridgewater and Hebron students have
been a minority among students enrolled
in the school
children from other towns within that
SAU have always been welcome to attend
going on quickly here that this bill is
designed to expand the legal status
as a village district and explore Over a
four-year period of time the
establishment of three-town special
purpose
School District
so we're looking at
transforming this also into a school
district this is a multi-step process
and the first step is to hold a vote in
Bridgewater Hebron and Groton to
determine if our citizens want to
establish a K-8 SAU
the intent of this bill is to improve
educational outcomes for children with
an Innovative alternative to a
traditional Middle School
the goal is to reconfigure the Village
School to a K-8 that's the eventual goal
that they're working towards
Studies have shown the fewer number of
transition transitions children make
before high school the greater
Improvement of student performance I can
attest to that as a principal for a
number of years will remain of a k
through eight those K-8 students go
through a situation like that where
teachers work with each other at
different levels you oftentimes can talk
to a fifth grade teacher uh maybe talks
with a sixth grade teacher a sixth grade
teacher said how did you ever figure
Johnny out and fifth grade teacher said
this is how I did it and you learn from
each other that's one of the neat things
about a K-8 school you have a similar
culture there's less transition for
students and the students get to know
each other well that's both good and bad
but it's a situation that I would say
it's the best organizational structure
that I've ever had I've had k-6s I've
had K eights I've had three through six
I've had four through six and I've had
middle school and high school and the
best fun I ever had was k through eight
so they operate their own Elementary
School and tuition into the Newfound
area district for grades seven through
twelve that's what they're aiming for
um so that's a little bit about the
background what this bill is trying to
do they're trying to uh do this
transition step from where they are
where they're not a school district
right now but they're also seeing when
the students move from the K-8 into the
middle school the math achievement
scores do drop and learning drops I I
don't know the total reasons for that
but you know I'm sure that their folks
here that may know that
um it's not that
um
I I don't want to say anything about
what that but I do know that in going
this direction they've assured me that
there's whether there's a union there
now the continued can they can reform
and do that teachers that are hired in
in the building right now will have the
option be hired in the building in the
future that's what they're looking at
there's not going to be any loss of
personnel the end result is that they
want to have the ability to figure out
twisting where they want students to go
once they finish the Elementary grades k
through eight
and um so that's where we are with the
bill I'd be glad to take any questions
or answers on this that's all I have Mr
chair thank you representative Ford did
you have anything to add
foreign
sorry
um would you like to gavel back Mr
chairman
you see girl you know okay I'll take it
back from there and then week that are
there any questions from the committee
representative miler
thank you uh uh chair Ladd and thanks
for that explanation without even
looking at the merits of The Proposal
here I have one question why is this
proposal before us
cannot cannot the study
that they're asking for the three or
four year study and the vote why does
this have to be a legislative action
I'm not looking at the merits I'm just
it's it's a procedural question that I'm
asking okay would you mind if we get
that technical advice from them that
would be great thank you so was it Mr
Looney and Mr Berry please come forward
um
I think if you met both of these
individual parts that is uh Virginia
Barry's husband
Commissioner of education and Bill Ludy
so at the hearing
um we presented a legal analysis
um that essentially
uh says that the legislature retains the
authority over the formulation of public
school districts and that was done by
the legal advisor for
the Hebron Bridgewater Village District
that we've had in place for about 22
years now just a follow-up thing yeah
yes so you're saying that the study that
that's proposed here I was a three-year
four-year study before you have a vote
of et cetera that that can't take place
prior to any legislation or do you need
the enabling legislation yes sir to to
conduct that kind of a process that is
correct sir yes we we need enabling
legislation if you recall in 1997 the
legislature passed a statute to create
the Bridgewater Hebron Village District
this is as the chairman mentioned this
is a
political unique political subdivision
we have three elected Commissioners so
our commissioners wanted to pursue
enabling legislation to give our towns
the opportunity to
have a vote on whether or not we want to
establish our own three-town school
district and then our selectment
according to the language in the bill
would appoint committees
to study how we would go about doing
that and so this bill essentially
is an enabling legislation to start that
process given our unique situation as a
village district and we own our own
School
as far as we know there is no other
towns in the entire state that has this
unique legislative status as a village
District
so just as a follow-up thing so because
it was initiated by the legislature
that's why you're here because that is
correct in other words our legal advisor
essentially said to us there's a there's
a flaw
in the original legislation and what
this enabling legislation does is
correct that flaw and brings us into
alignment with the village District
and once this enabling legislation has
passed then it's entirely up to our
towns to decide whether or not we want
to establish our own Freetown school
district and then the legislation was
carefully written as a series of steps
once that vote took place in order to
achieve on the creation of our own
school district and our own SAU
and was that the letter that you
provided US during the hearing process
from Dean Eggert Wadley Starr and Peters
here that is correct and his point was
and for full you know stipulation here I
am not a lawyer all right but I we we
did hand out and I read into the record
during the hearing
This legal issue and we had 20 copies of
the letter available for all of the
members here but essentially what his
legal opinion says is that you the
legislature retained the authority to do
this and then secondly he said this bill
corrects a unique flaw in The
Cooperative withdrawal process and
finally he said as a local act this bill
does not modify the general Provisions
pertaining to any other school district
trying with the with the RSA 195
withdrawal process
so again this is simply an enabling
piece of legislation to allow our three
towns to expand on that Statute in 1997
creating the village district with our
three elected Commissioners and move to
a full School District in SAU and we
present a testimony during the hearing
on why we think that's not only good for
Education outcomes but it's good for
parents it's good for local control and
we certainly hope that we'll get your
support
are there further questions for either
yes representative luno yes thank you
very much Mr chair and thanks for uh for
being here today I know it's been a long
morning uh here as well
um but um but you know this is a a
um you know rather unique type of Bill
to come come before the committee and
and I I do have a couple of questions if
the chair would go ahead dulls me on
this go ahead um the the first one is
would the I I guess is there opposition
within the Newfound Area School District
to the withdrawal of Bridgewater uh
Hebron and Groton and will that
withdrawal
um will it withdrawal be uh predicated
on a vote by the full Newfound Area
School District
so the answer to your questions
um representative Leno is that
um there's this is just my own personal
view there's a mixed reaction throughout
the school district but in our three
towns
254 people signed in in support of this
bill during the testimony and there were
four opposed so just based on that sort
of rudimentary you know indication of
whether or not there's support in our
three towns there is it's unknown to me
there's tremendous support in our three
towns for this and our Selectmen all
nine Selectmen we're here at the
Committee hearing
um and testified
um I think quite eloquently
um about why this makes sense not only
from
this unique legal status that we have
and the fact that we own our own school
but also we have a 300 mile square mile
School District it's huge and our three
towns are on the north end of it and a
lot of the testimony that our citizens
gave to your committee a few weeks ago
said you know our kids spend two and a
half hours on a bus and we could cut
that down by making a smaller School
District so our kids wouldn't have to
drive by a middle school you know
waiting at the middle school and to go
another 30 minutes to get to um so just
a school so so I can't answer your
question about the because we haven't
done any polling if you will about what
the other
towns think but this would not require
this bill would require just the votes
of our three towns so so just to be
clear uh Mr chair this um this is more
than enabling legislation
in line six through eight on the first
page the towns of Bridgewater Hebron are
hereby authorized to withdraw from the
Newfound Area School District and
establish a public school district and
buys that comprise of the geographical
limits of the aforementioned three towns
period
um so so
does does that provision in here
complete the withdrawal of these three
towns
from the I mean from a from a legal
standpoint does it complete the with the
the authorization of the withdrawal of
these three towns from the Newfound Area
School District without a vote of Adam
at a meeting
of the Newfound Area School District and
all the towns that comprise it line 14
says the career and this is after the
one that you you've quoted sir
um the creation of this new Public
School District shall be contingent upon
a majority vote in each of the three
towns right right and I've got that
right underlined as well so that's not
the withdrawal that's the next step
that's the creation of the district and
the vote is only from the people that
reside voters in those three towns
that's correct not voters throughout the
Newfound Area School District correct so
so my concern and it's a a deeply held
concern and this comes out of my
Commerce time Mr chair is that is that
these three towns are currently in a in
an agreement
with the Newfound Area School District
and this bill
is
having legislative action
to essentially interfere with that
agreement
I and I'm not arguing on them you know
as representative Miler said I I think
the case you're making is is strong for
the three towns to withdraw but I'm
wondering I mean I'm really concerned if
if if this will become serve as
precedent for for state government to
get involved with right yeah I answer
that question yeah yeah according to our
legal advisor
um and I will again I read this into the
record
um Let me let me go through it again
and I'll be happy to provide you with a
copy of this legal analysis that might
help answer the the questions better
than I can do but aside from the
legislature retaining the authority to
do this
um it it essentially says this law this
is a local act it does not modify the
general Provisions pertaining to other
Cooperative School District when it's
all process and the reason that this is
the case is this is a very unique set of
facts
we have a statute that created a village
District
we've been leasing we built our own
School
trust about what eight million dollars
back now two thousand
it costs about five right we have a
separate line item on our Town's tax
bill
that you know where you have your local
property tax your Statewide education
property tax and the third line item is
Village District tax
and we tax our citizens to the tune of
175 to 200 000 a year just Bridgewater
and Hebron not the other five towns in
the school district
to take care of repair maintenance and
Capital Improvements we've built a
greenhouse industrial Greenhouse we put
new roofs on new boilers the school the
Newfound Area School District pays for
the custodial services in their larger
contract but our citizens are taxed and
paid for the um upkeep and Capital
Improvements of the school so if I may
quote from our legal advisor at first
blush there may be reluctance on the
part of some to adopt this bill
due to the fact that it creates a more
nuanced withdrawal process however
this bill applies to a local situation
where a separate municipality owns the
building in which the children are
educated it is not capable of repetition
and represents a truly unique set of
facts
that's the best way I can answer your
question yeah yeah no thanks and and
and I guess
um
yeah don't wait wait short of
well I I I guess it I mean it sounds it
sounds pretty clear to me that that
the the involvement of Bridgewater have
run and and and
um growth in in the Newfound Area School
District isn't working out for the the
the people in those three towns
um and the students too and and so long
bus rides we spend a lot of money
maintaining school that's used
four four K-5 for the district right for
for the district including kids that
live in other towns
and
um and that
that
essentially I mean what what appears to
me and again I'm I'm I I sympathize with
with your case but but I I can't
separate this from from essentially an
Ask of the legislature to intervene with
a with an existing Cooperative uh
agreement uh between each of the the
three towns and the Newfound Area School
District and and while I while I respect
um Dean Eggert
um you know his paragraph at first blush
on this and and you know Dean's been our
attorney in Hopkinton you know from from
time to time too and and and I my wife's
an attorney so a lawyer so I I
understand you know what lawyers do
um that that
I'm
I I guess I'm not
I I don't understand why this situation
is any different than any other
Cooperative School District agreement
by virtue of the the legality of the
agreement itself and not by the
situation of owning schools K-5 we pay
for all the operating costs you know
terms that that may have sounded good
back when you got into the agreement but
um you know back in
97 back in 97 but but now have sort of
worn thin and and I guess I I I don't
see from attorney eggert's letter
how the uh how the framework of the
agreement is somehow
different enough from the Frameworks and
other agreement in other Co-op
agreements throughout the state that
would that would require
um legislative uh
uh action to to to
essentially break the agreement because
that's what's happening in in line six
through eight all right make a comment
uh first this is really good for kids
right off the bat
it was not a problem about having a vote
of the school district when we turned
around and suggested building a school
and turning around and leasing it back
to them and they've had educational
control so we've had a very good
separation of church and state we don't
want to run a school however what
happens now is is basically it's going
you know it's like a helicopter at the
same and no one's going to change this
unless we turn around and make some
changes we've wanted to work with the
school district we will continue to work
with the school district
in terms of being being a separate
District but they that's a home district
and so no one's going to turn around and
we have a history in the last 22 years
of never ever turning them down for
anything they wanted in that school
okay and that will continue
and it won't be on a piece of paper is
because a little competition in this
otherwise we're going to turn around and
we're going to have the same exact mold
that we have presently and nothing will
move forward
in these particular cases and they're
already you know when there was we've
lost 500 kids but at the time they were
packed at the gills and the solution we
came up with we couldn't get the other
towns because of diverse this the way
this seven Town district is pulling in
different directions we had no way of
turning around and solving the
overcrowding that was at the time
and so we came here because of that
issue specifically and we've turned
around and done a really unique job here
and so all we're asking now is to
continue that unique job and you'll find
that when the other towns see that you
can turn around and have a k through
eight they will not vote for a K-8
they've already turned us down two times
and it will continue to stay okay
through five and in fact we don't even
know if they'll do that if and pull kids
out of the school it's it isn't just
that the other towns can come to the
school of that no the the district
agreement that we have presently turns
around as an addendum effectively turns
around and mandates that if they if if
we only if I a number of kids in our
school drops in half that school will
always be full because they'll come in
from the other towns to turn around and
bust them in from say Bristol the next
door neighbor or from Alexandria
so it is not an evil thing it doesn't
have anything that's going to have
anybody else to turn around and try to
Super exceed any of the authorities in
any other District but at the very
beginning we stepped outside of our
agreements and if you can find it in
communities that have stepped outside of
their agreements voluntarily
to do this but I can tell you that if we
just turn around and go back and ask to
do anything it comes down to the
basically just one size fits all
and it will not change and it's the
other the other thing here is no one's
going to get hurt by this and the ones
that will benefit will be the children
representative Lino again
um Dean couldn't be here today because
he was in poor so sort of at a
disadvantage in trying to
um explain his his big reasoning here
but paragraph two in the letter is the
best that I can do
um
your question about the larger
Cooperative School District he says that
this corrects
a unique flaw in The Cooperative
withdrawal process because the nature of
our separate political entity there's no
other place in the in the state that has
a village District that built and owns
and operates its own School maintenance
wise and repair wise and has three
elected Commissioners so he thinks that
this bill will correct that flaw and
realign us with the statutes that are
for Cooperative school districts all
right and by by rearranging our
relationship with the Bridgewater Hebron
Village District that three
Commissioners that are elected for
certain number of terms two and three
and four year terms
that's the best explanation I can give
to your answer and it's unfortunate that
he's in court today because I think he
would have been able to expound a little
bit more on that but paragraph two I
think is an attempt to answer your your
question
Mr Looney um back in 1997
when HB 436 then
identified this special Village District
was there any discussion done that you
may know I I see Senator Rubens was on
he's still around but was there any
um
any discussion regarding Maybe
making it also a school district
at the same time
not at that time not at that time okay
is there anything in this legislation
that's going to be detrimental to
Newfound no no we don't think so it's
because we own our own school there's
going to be no settlement of assets and
liabilities we don't have to buy our
school back
um and we had we presented testimony
representative Leno um on at the hearing
where we have a we have actually an
elected budget Newfound Area School
District budget official behind me and
then the Bridgewater elected budget
committee
um person presented a
budget issue or the economic aspects of
this by saying we're simply going to
shift
the costs the operational cost of our
three towns
I believe the budget person who
testified said that right now our three
towns are 15 percent
of the student population in the greater
Newfound Area School District and we
represent about 16 percent of the cost
so we thought this through very
carefully and if we're allowed to create
our own School District to correct that
deficiency that Dean Eggert pointed out
that flaw then there's little to no cost
to the Newfound Area School District in
fact There's an opportunity for them
because we would have to enter into
tuition agreements to send our high
school kids to Newfound or Plymouth and
we have approximately 47 high school
kids that would equate to if you use
nineteen thousand five hundred that
would create a revenue stream for
Newfound Area School District of about
eight hundred thousand dollars a year
we also have in the bill that we would
enter into service contracts with the
Newfound Area School District because we
would be a small a smaller School
District geographically and with student
enrollment where we would pay them
to handle all of our back office work
and we know from our I mean Hebron has
500 people folks it's a small little
town
um you know Groton has about the salmon
I think Bridgewater has about about a
thousands about a thousand
so it's a small community and we know
and our our citizens know that we would
have to in fact raise taxes to do this
we want to put an addition on the school
we think it would cost us about a
million a million and a half dollars the
pl the school was built in 2000 with
expansion in mind the plumbing is
already in the ground there's two
boilers all the HVAC is you know the
plumbing is ready to go so we our
citizens are willing to raise taxes to
put an addition on the school to create
a k through eight again for all the
education reasons that are people who
came and testified a few weeks ago on
why a K-8 is a good idea so we're
willing to put the cost for all this
but we need something to enable this to
happen
um because where as as selectman Murphy
said we're in a situation now by this
unique situation where we not only own
our own school but we have this
political subdivision what we're simply
trying to do is expand on that to create
a official School District
yeah thank you thank you
um you you just mentioned that um that
if you were separate districts and you
you certainly wouldn't you'd have a k
solution within the district but you'd
need a a 912 uh nine to twelve High
School solution and and one of those
could be tuitioning
um back to the Newfound Area School
District High School uh at a cost of
maybe around eight hundred thousand
dollars how much currently is um are the
three towns contributing revenue-wise so
local property tax wise to the um to the
uh uh to the the new fund District
what's the question you have no I think
you wanted to know which each Town
contributes yeah just just sort of
roughly yeah of this in ADM system it's
100 ADM
so there is no there's no property
values associated with it that's in your
agreement there's articles of agreement
well is this potty that's in the
Articles of agreement uh per pupils all
based on ADM yes
so representative and I I if I hear your
question correctly
if you take our local property tax
the Statewide education property tax and
then the separate tax that Bridgewater
and Hebron have to maintain the struggle
um we have 48 students
and that equates to about twenty one
thousand seven hundred and sixty nine
thousand dollars per student to
um that we contribute to the Newfound
Area School District
Bridgewater is about 19 285 and Hebron
correction Groton is about
um thirteen thousand fourteen thousand
dollars
so that's how much we currently
contribute so it's a lot more than eight
hundred thousand dollars in in the
aggregate not eight hundred thousand it
depends on what the tuition agreement
do you know if um if the Newfound Area
School District currently has any debt
I think it's I think they're out of debt
so
even if they weren't we'd be obligated
to turn around and pay that portion off
and we did they did a um uh it's quite a
while ago now so it should have been
amatized by now they turned around and
did some upgrades in their heating
systems across all their schools and
then bonded it up in 20 or 30 years I
think it's all paid for but even if that
wasn't the case we would turn around and
that would be Our obligation to pay that
off the um what effectively this does is
to turn around and and make a
seven-member board a four and a
three-member board and by that you get
you're making the decision making a
little cleaner and easier to work with
you know how it is and just getting
agreements in committees when they're
large and they also have different
points of view because we're so far
apart so this improves decision making
it improves the ability to turn onto a
different model and has that different
model if it's and I believe it'll be
successful uh would turn around and
motivate the other towns to do different
things when we moved in into this
agreement uh schools went up and schools
are significantly high in the school and
it's helped the elementary schools and
and pull up their stuff so there's been
no negative downturn on this at all so
in terms of past history and there's no
intention for us quite frankly uh I'm
the one that says you know I don't think
anybody wants to run a school they're
very very difficult very complicated to
run a school but they've done a really
good job in a physical plant and all we
want to do is facilitate that and move
forward without hurting anybody else and
no one is going to get it and that I
think is obviously the the sense of
concern that that that we have not being
feet on the ground you know on what's
going on here any senses to what the the
um and I know I'm getting down to the
weeds I apologize for the members of the
committee to to
um and Mr chair
of equalized property valuations per
pupil and how that may um may be
different across and I don't even know
how many member towns there are the
Newfoundland School District but but um
uh for example this committee has heard
testimony about how when Cooperative
districts of many Cooperative districts
were originally formed
um many of the districts included some
towns with with high property values
along with some towns with low property
values and that was designed to to to
make make
Public School more affordable to to all
of the towns involved so when we're
talking about about withdrawal from a
from a district
um I'm I'm wondering about what's what's
being withdrawn and what's what's left
and what that does to property taxes in
the communities that are left and
you know I for one would want to see a
much much more detailed analysis we've
already done that yeah no I'm I'm not
but I'm just saying that we just had it
we just had a review of the property tax
system through the towns and we set up a
separate study committee for that study
committee came back with effectively no
decision because the current one is the
fairest one that we could come up with
which is everyone pays between 19 to 21
000 in spite of evaluations around if I
was to ask which has the biggest
evaluation it would actually be that the
adjoining town of Bristol but if I ask
people what who is the richest town
around the continent and support then
they'd say it would be Bridgewater or
Heber because of the tax rate
differences so even even because the psf
tax rate differences the tax rate is
lower in Bridgewater and Hebron and but
the tax base and Bristol is quite a bit
higher
but in general that we already reviewed
that uh in the study committee that was
uh brought up and we just finished back
in August and a report was put out so
that you know as far as
um will it have an impact on the
Newfound Area School District that will
have no Financial impact whatsoever
so no not no tax no impact and
representative I know on your earlier
question
um on on tuition agreements currently
the Newfound high school has a capacity
for uh 500 students
320 are enrolled right now and while 40
of that 320 are the high school kids
from our town so there's a there's a big
hole there and we have said in all of
our we we've spoken to
um we provided Point papers data
analyzes to our three school board
members from Bridgewater Hebron and
Groton and
um we think that by going to this having
this legislation to help us move along
we do it in complete cooperation with
the Newfound Area School District we had
a budget person come in with the
analysis during the hearing and saying
there's little to no cost
um economic cost to the Newfound area
school district and the education
outcomes we know from studies about k
through eight are just you know huge so
this piece of legislation will help us
start the ball rolling and we fully
intend to work in Total cooperation with
the Newfound Area School District if
this legislation is passed and that's
why there's a four-year period and so
many steps that you have to go through
um so that's where we are we've done a
lot of the analysis already but our the
bill will actually authorizes our
selectment in our three towns to set up
committees right to take the data that
we've already done
to try to have this best outcome for our
kids and then they will expand on that
step by step according to this piece of
legislation I hope that helps yeah well
I mean I'm I'm certain that that that
the three towns are going to do a very
competent and and solid job of that I'm
worried about what happens in in the
other towns and and and I'm sorry I I
missed what you're are you with I I am a
I was appointed by my town to serve on
the study committee that looked at the
apportionment formula then the district
commissioners
asked me to continue that work
um because of the knowledge that I
gained from serving on that committee
for seven months to continue to assist
in this legislative okay and and um and
have has what was was is the this
legislation here was this developed in
collaboration with with let's say the
superintendent and the business
administrator at Newfound area the chain
of Commander if you want a retired naval
officer um was the village District
commission yep took this upon themselves
to ask to start the legislative relief
so has this committee heard oh that's
that's yeah you know you're getting a
dialogue going in yeah no I know I
appreciate it um yeah so I make one
comment we we ended up in two different
occasions in the last 20 years to ask to
turn around and convert the school to a
k through k through eight
um and and both you know and the second
one was in terms of withdrawal we
withdrew from the whole idea when
because there was a possibility that the
other school can the kids from the other
towns that come to that presently come
to that school they would not come which
we found that kind of unusual
but at that time we withdrew from it
because the history has been a really
good relationship there's no reason to
turn around and think that this is going
to hurt anybody and the only there we
will not be able to go to K-8 I've been
a Stockman for 45 years
and God only knows how I did that but
but anyways and the commissioner on this
thing
this this gives people some choice
it's not at the expense of anybody else
and if it was at the expense of anybody
else I wouldn't be here right now it's
not gonna it's gonna be neutral we had
no reason to turn around and have to
step outside the contractor the initial
Charter
um they already have another school
district in this which is the Hill
School District that stepped away from
Franklin and then they tuition into the
sixth through the 6th through 12th grade
in Newfound Area School District so this
is not something that it and in fact
they're trying to get them to join
apparently but I don't know what the
politics of that are there is nothing
that has ever gone on in this that has
turned around a bit at the expense of
another town
ever this legislation was crafted just
to do the exact same thing not to impact
negatively either education wise or cost
of taxes or anything else so that we can
turn around and move forward and be a
leader in the education business
and it gives parents some choice and if
parents if they if we have open seats
and somebody doesn't want to go to the
middle school they can turn around
certainly have the option of being
coming come here and the best the best
model would be the SAU model right now
when you're a single school district is
basically that there is no SAU board the
SAU bought in the Cooperative School
daughter joined this would give us the
opportunity to turn around in two two
School District board then you would
have three people from each side being
on the SAU board for administrative
costs there's no sense for us to turn
around and try to reinvent the wheel of
the talented people who turn around it
represents and work in the school
district itself
okay the superintendent other business
managers other people who do the payroll
the union contracts and so on no one's
going to lose their jobs some kids are
going to get pushed out and so on that's
fantastic you're very benign you have
any questions I do
um I was looking back in my notes at the
at the hearing and uh superintendent
Couture in his testimony said that
um
that the that this particular Bill had
never been presented to him or this the
school board has that been resolved do
they have you had meetings since then
that has resolved it seemed like there
was some real animosity uh there in at
least in my notes they've had all of the
information that we gave them they've
had no meetings on it
yeah all of the um Point papers that we
developed from the village District
commission have been distributed to all
the school current seven-member school
board and
um and so I think everyone is sort of
waiting to see
whether or not this legislation passes
all right and then we all intend to work
together to um to to make this um change
uh the best way that we can
what happens to this legislation in four
years time nothing's happening
we stay in the school district so this
legislation goes away it's there's an
exploration my understanding from Dean
is there's an expiration on this in four
years okay
what are the questions from the
committee
yes repson Woodcock Anthony gentleman I
was looking through my notes as well the
only I remember distinctly I wrote it
twice
um and maybe you can refresh because
representative Luna wasn't here the
superintendent uh from the uh town uh
from Newfound era was the only one who
spoke basically from the school district
and he was adamantly opposed
um and I don't have I have some of his
quotes but I don't I couldn't capture
the exact reason why I was adamantly
opposed can you just refresh me on that
um well
over the last 22 years we've had five
superintendents including him okay so
you know the in the problem with the
school district is that the seven towns
tend to pull in different directions in
there he was aware we tried to get him
as well more aware of it but the reality
is is that I don't know what his
opposition is at this point in time but
basically it's easier to keep the same
existing structure this Cooperative
school district is easier to manage and
say yes I do 40h which I was a
consultant about 10 years on the
technology stuff
um the uh you have one school board to
deal with and so on but Plymouth has
multiple school boards that they have to
work with and so on but it puts the
decision making closer to the the people
in the in the in those adjoining towns
it's easier to pass legislation than the
town so you turn around and past budgets
and so on because I see it you don't
erase uh the the identity of the town
when you're sitting on a seven-membered
group we have a we have a not only is a
large District but it's also a
significantly different uh socioeconomic
background so basically it's very hard
to get anything done in this thing I
mean if if we were if we didn't step up
to the plate to build a school back into
in in 2000
they wouldn't have voted to turn around
and expand and build a new building
guaranteed you know that's just because
the fact is is that they they have a
they they seem to be supportive of their
own School District but he's only been
in the business about three years or so
in the in the job but there's a there's
there's different personalities in
different and different likes and
dislikes
so for us to turn around and step out of
the district and build the school and
hand over the educational quality
they've done a terrific job we're not
going to turn around and upset that
airport okay okay thank you thank you Mr
chair you're welcome I've been by the
school and it's a beautiful school
um why is it that you all are willing to
lease that facility which is so
wonderful facility why are you willing
to lease this out to the Newfound school
district at just a dollar a year
uh
well you know we have an advantage in
terms of tax base and basically stood up
to the plate and said we should help out
and so uh why we why would we turn
around and build a school to put our
kids in even as a minority and then turn
around and try to charge them a much
higher rate or try to amortize the cost
of the building off of it
so
um and we've been fairly clever in terms
of building infrastructure over the
years and paying for it as we go so it
just seemed to be the natural thing to
do is it you know we're not looking to
take something from anybody and that
won't build good neighbors
if you turn around and just turn around
and try to you know we have we want to
do this and if that your expense it
hasn't been that way in 20 years and it
will not happen it's built into our
contracts and so on there are some
limits in terms of some of these things
but for the most part the only thing I
think there was anything really major in
it was the fact that
um
when we transport kids that we didn't
want you know if it'd be hard to sell
the the bond issue if I if I say well
your kid your child will you go to the
town of New Hampton School because
they're closer so we put in that closet
said they have to come here and the only
other Clause that's changed over lost 20
some odd years was that if you have 15
kids in a classroom in New Hampton
Bristol Danbury uh and Danbury and
they're all at 15 we don't want 25 in a
classroom
um and that was put in there to turn
around and say whatever the average is
and all your other elementary schools
then the classroom structure should be
about and they they might float up a
little bit down there we also took over
all of these space facilities for
um preschool
we offered just recently to turn around
and consider building another couple of
classrooms on the building to
accommodate kids with um
yeah I was a significant disabilities
yeah
um developmental disabilities so to turn
around and make that that works and so
we've you know we're not gonna you know
um it's just sharing everything with
everybody else thank you that's what I'm
looking for are there further questions
from the committee
okay yes representing cascadden
um just something that I'm struggling
with a little bit and I think I
understand the whole request or the
needs are
and we have laws on the books for
withdrawal process and if that law is
not applicable to this type of situation
maybe there needs to be a law that is
what what I what I'm uncomfortable with
is that specific towns and then thinking
of the North Country I think of the town
of Milan in the Milan Village School
in a similar situation so if we agree to
three towns and then we get another
request is there any applicability I
mean should I be concerned about that
yes it just opens the door is a unique
difference here as it's been alluded to
by both the men in front of us well I
heard that at the by Statute we did this
back in 1997 yeah and made them a
special district
and whereas the towns you're talking
about aren't that okay this is the only
place in the state of New Hampshire
that is what they are uh I can't think
of any other well I in even in my own
town Woodsville the only reason why we
had a highway department for a village
district is was done by statutory law
here in the house in the Senate but that
there's only a few places where that
type of thing has occurred okay and in
this regard this is the only place where
this one is so then this law would undo
that well this law is going to try to
correct correct what was done what we
have and what appears was done three
quarters away and didn't go the other
quarter by doing what they could and
then you really are a participant as a
member in that SAU because you are a
separate School District which they
don't have that but they have everything
that most school districts do have
except the authority to do what they do
what they want to do yeah okay yeah all
right represent Balboni uh just a
follow-up to uh representative Cass
cabin was talking about so basically the
difference is that was was formed by the
legislature whereas other saus and
Cooperative school districts are formed
with the consent of the towns is that
the difference it's a whole different
process okay the the those other school
districts and sau's were formed
initially when this process
reorganization of Satan probably if your
wife could probably tell me a whole lot
more about that because I wasn't here in
the state of town I was you know four
thousand five miles from here so but
it's a whole different
statutory area than what they have this
is so unique it's unusual The Village
District statutes that exist in audit
into what we did would have to buy out
the school or the facility you're
talking about
you know they don't own they don't own
the land they don't own the buildings
and so on and that's not to me a big
deal I think the educational component
of is more important but if you turn
around and said you have towns that have
a village District school that's a name
it is no it has no political subdivision
it has no ownership to it because it
would be owned by the school district
and so you if you were to turn around
and withdraw from the school district
your first obligation is to pay off the
debt and I think the next one would be
to convince them to either give you the
school back or to buy the school back
and that would there would be a lot of
hurdles
can I just ask him one more quick
question right so just okay I live in
Rye and I'm a part of an SAU and in why
we own our school we have two of them
and and there is a process for
withdrawal from the district I'm just
trying to wrap my head around how your
process is different that's what I was
trying to get at it was it or with the
origination they're not a town okay
Village District it's just like a fire
district or a water district they're a
village District that's a whole like in
my town we got five districts within
Haverhill Woodsville is a fire district
yes this is you sir would it be fair
then to summarize this that there is no
other legislation uh for withdrawal any
of the private school districts they'll
be impacted any other any other
Cooperative school district will not be
impacted by this that's all the fall
this is the only singular one this is
not going to have anything to do with
Cooperative school districts
disillusionment or withdrawing Etc yep
thanks sir yeah thank you thank you very
much I understand that there's a request
you might check to see if there's a room
yeah well that Judiciary as you even
tried down on the other side even
we're at two o'clock in the afternoon
anymore
we're cooking horse meat we're still
good right
yeah
I'm ready to roast the horse that
thing's been beaten tender
yeah but yeah they're going to come back
in 10 10.
we're going to go ahead here now
um
at this point in time I think we're at
the point where
we discussed this thing and we've had
the caucus and now what we are I think
we're ready Madam clerk to go ahead and
call the roll
um this is 349 relative to a special
purpose school district for Bridgewater
Hebron and Groton that's the title of
the ACT
and
um with that would you please call the
then the motion on the table is OTP
would you please call the role of Madam
Clerk
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative blackis yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Peter now yes representative cortielo
yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner no
Representative luno no
representative Ellison yes
representative Wilcox yes
representative Paul yes
yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes
18 years two names representative miles
is there any opposition to consent
so this will go on the consent calendar
thank you very much
we have uh I would like to get this
thing done here
we have four bills left
uh we skipped over we're going to skip
um what were we waiting for we waiting
for what's happening on on session day
tomorrow that's EFA bill
so we're gonna Skip and hold that one
um
to Monday of of next week so we would
then jump right down now into 516
uh not jump just fall down through it
relative to to uh freedom of speech and
Association at public institutions of
representative cordial you're recognized
for no Rex representative McDonald
you'll recognize for a motion thank you
Mr chair I move that we find this ought
to pass
is there a second
representative Ford second bit
rep representative McDonald
yes thank you this spill is needed at
this time as we heard substantial
testimony from many constituents across
the state saying that they felt
personally targeted and that this
legislation would help them and it is
also necessary for preventing Free
Speech zones whereas in certain areas of
a campus it's okay to have free speech
and in the rest of the University could
designate that it's not
and in addition I'd like to remind the
committee that this has bipartisan
support in bipartisan sponsors as well
and in addition I do have an amendment
to put forward thank you okay so uh who
second that or representative that's
correct
um representative uh McDonald you said
you had an amendment yes did you pass it
around please so we can see what that's
the amendments are coming around it is a
simple so why should we still everybody
you might just expedite things try to
show me the line maybe where the changes
may occur or or change or whatever you
everything
okay
okay I believe those are getting around
all right
I'm bringing this amendment forward on
behalf of the Prime sponsor
representative property Mueller
it changes one word if you look online
free of the amendment it says any person
or student organization
that is a change from Student
Association to student organization this
was recommended by a number of attorneys
and lawyers presence
saying that this will keep the language
more consistent and more clarity and
so it only changes that one line line
okay then it's in keeping with the
definition on page two student
organization
further discussion
yes representative Tanner we've had
several bills in the past on free speech
on campus
and when uh and I've been on a
subcommittee for that and our State
University's Plymouth Keen uh UNH have
done a tremendous job updating their
their procedures and policies uh and
actually we're to the point where
they're approved by a group called fire
which was a big Free Speech one one of
the areas that I particularly had
problems with was the outdoor areas of
the campus the campus includes
dormitories and learning areas and
having taught on on campus before that
just having lawnmowers and stuff outside
the campus windows can really interfere
with what you're doing and I ca I just
can't imagine having protests by the
dormitories where you're trying to sleep
or you're trying to to
um
study or even classes if it's allowed in
raucous uh protest this University
protests usually are
um
and and that's one of my issues with uh
with the Bill thank you thank you
further discussion represent Miler thank
you Mr chair
one of the things I've learned in my
lifetime
as old as it might be
is that there are two sides to every
story
and we ended the uh hearing last time
with some students from UNH law that
were concerned about how they were dealt
with in their application
and so what I did is I called Dean
Cooper
who was the assistant Dean at the law
school
Mr Cooper is the one who sits on the
student bar that basically authorizes
all the various organizations on campus
and so here here is what I found from
him
the group that we that was referenced
here which they never gave their name is
called the free exercise coalition
they made their application to the
university for recognition
in the late November
late November is just before finals and
before the re the holiday recess
the next meeting that was scheduled was
in January
at that November meeting
the student Bar Association thought they
needed more information before they
would act on it
they did their due diligence
and when they met in January
this group was authorized as an
organization on campus
so there wasn't an implication by them
that they weren't authorized but we
never asked the question were you
ultimately authorized so we now know
that they help them they are authorized
and in fact the process that was
followed for their authorization is the
normal process that you go through at
the evidently at the law school
you should also know that there's a
Jewish law Association
and there's also a Christian legal
Society
I think one of the and at the same time
that they were dealing with an issue in
the November meeting there was a group
that wanted to have a Spanish
organization and that organization has
yet to be authorized
so I think to try to to bring at least
that piece of the conclusion of it which
bothered me a little bit when I was
hearing the feedback was that a the
process was followed be there ultimately
uh authorized so from a standpoint of
being discriminated against which is
what kind of what I was hearing from the
group they clearly weren't discriminated
against they are basically dealt with in
an appropriate way through the
procedures that the that the university
that the law school follows so I just
wanted to have that for the record Mr
chair
so in in filing that uh Professor Milo
at the Spanish group
uh did do you have to have a professor
sponsoring your organization or somebody
from the college doing that or how's
that work I don't know that I do know
that once you authorized you I think the
school gives them the organization 200
or something to to operate the program
thank you if I may yes yeah I would just
like to follow up now that I've got that
history here uh I would just Echo what
uh uh representative uh tanneris said is
that we have had this issue before this
committee a number of times in fact at
one point in time there was some serious
concerns about how the University was in
fact handling uh free speech on campus
uh our understanding is basically
through the testimony that we heard that
day that the university has in fact uh
dealt with this issue they ranked 16 out
of 203 uh universities or schools that
the fire uh monitors and they've either
they've admitted that this that they
have done a good job and frankly I don't
see the need for this particular bill at
this point in time because of the the
good due diligence that the university
has done to provide free speech on
from yes representative uh we're dry
thank you Mr chairman I've got my
handouts from that day and they're like
six or seven pages listed free exercise
Coalition introducing the people from
that group so I
can't believe we didn't know who they
were I think what they took exception to
was the way that they were treated not
necessarily how long it took for them to
get recognized as a group but some of
uh Rough Waters trying to get um
acceptance at the University I believe
that that was
more of a um
a problem than how long it took them to
get their affiliation thank you
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair and just defer a
client here I'll further clarify that
point
um for this student organization I
believe they did make it clear that they
were ultimately recognized after having
an attorney get involved I believe their
primary concern was that they were
subject to significant disparaging
remarks and bullying
um including from members of student
government per their testimony and
further that their sincerely held
beliefs in their statement was subject
to excessive scrutiny and took
significant uh do doing to get approved
as a student group so I don't think the
issue was that they weren't approved or
that they didn't have their name on it
but rather that behavior so to go a
little further into into what this bill
does I was one of the people who was
interested in watching a commentator
back in 2016 who was uh who was shouted
down at the University of New Hampshire
and I I wasn't able to uh to enjoy that
event unfortunately because despite
security being present they allowed the
event to be interrupted and this is a
pattern that has happened not not only
at certain schools here but across the
country and I applaud the university
that it has done better that it has
improved its score and this is an
excellent thing but I would remind you
all that we are coming up on another
presidential election season and it was
during the last presidential election
season that everything went off the
rails and I think we really stand to see
these kind of things possibly happening
again
in the next election season within the
next year or so if we don't do something
to actually prevent that
further discussion represent cascadden
um my thoughts are we are an elected
public body and we should be supporting
the university system I mean so I feel
strongly that if the the university
system
is against this Bell that I feel is an
elected official
it's a public school and I don't think
we should be voting for interest groups
we're voting for the public so I
represent Belcher or you had your hand
apologies just clarify on that point I I
think the interest group if there is any
interest group here is is not the public
who elected us who we have a right to or
a duty rather to represent but a
university would be an interest group
representative Ford thank you Mr chair
yeah
thank you
um
am I ready now I know are you I don't
know this is a question that's broader
than anything I've heard except perhaps
uh Mr belcher's comments on now it's
really a question of what is a
university without freedom of expression
and whether or not there's an incident
that somehow should be objected to or
not
nah that's like saying should we vote
against murder well it hasn't happened
yet so I guess we don't need an
objection to it
no this destroys a university if it does
not exist
whether it's one-on-one Groupon group
whatever if you cannot discuss it you
really don't have a university
that's what they're there for to discuss
any and all ideas without any barriers
whatsoever
otherwise you can't learn
representative cordelli
thank you Mr chairman uh two things
first I think we had testimony from the
first Liberty
organizations lawyer
um as well as his written testimony that
the issue was with the uh SBA
um in relation to the um
FEC Coalition
and according to his written testimony
after attorneys representing the uh
Christian legal Society wrote to you
this is to Dean Shane Cooper did UNH
formally recognize this student group
um secondly I I think that
policies are nice but policies come and
go I think if it is in statute we are a
lot better off as a state and with our
public
universities and I will note that there
are a number of areas in here where it
provides for
reasonable restrictions to be placed by
the um by an institution of Higher
Learning for instance May maintain and
enforce reasonable time place manner
restrictions
applicable public forums Etc
any person who wishes to engage in
non-commercial expressive activity on
campus should be free be permitted to do
so freely as long as the person's
conduct is not unlawful and is not
materially or substantially disrupt the
functioning of the institution
um so I think this language in this bill
Works to both freedom of Stu freedom of
speech for students and others on campus
foreign
thank you Mr chair uh given that
explanation uh
two of the people who have discussed
this talked about disparaging remarks
that were made on campus uh is there
anything this bill is going to keep an
individual from making disparaging
remarks about an organization or or
another individual based on
representative Cornett cordelli's last
quote I I would assume not I would
assume you that's fine that the
disparaging remarks depending on your
political philosophy or whatever are
five
and right this is all about freedom of
speech so um you know I think that's
what we're talking about
perhaps on woodcock
uh I I am for free of speech and I think
the university has representative Foley
says the place to have that that being
said we're talking about one small
instance of the entire University system
has come to our attention
um it's like a pebble in the ocean if we
have if we have if we have two three
four five ten people concerned
there's something there but what was it
it was corrected several years ago and
there's a process now I think I don't
think this is appropriate for us to
respond in this manner with a hammer uh
versus the tap the tabs are the the the
D the school start of several years ago
he fixed it this is one process that was
that was a skew
um and you know his kids kids go before
the kids on a board uh I think this is
just too much uh overreach thank you
Mercy McDonald
thank you Mr chair to address that
previous comment that this is an
isolated Incident That's not the case 17
states have passed similar laws because
there's a national need for this and
ACLU supports this bill in New Hampshire
because there's a demonstrated need so
that's not the case thank you
representative yes go ahead I always
wanted not to get a debate with you uh
representative but I'm not worried about
the other side with these states I worry
about the incidents of New Hampshire
which has been won last year amongst
what do you say five kids Association
I'm not suggesting is Right fear or
anything I'm just suggesting we don't
take the hammer at this point thank you
uh rev some balbuni I'm representing the
ACLU statement that he was presented
um there actually was no documentation
of that and when I went back to the
sponsor of the bill and asked for that I
did not receive it even though the uh
the uh
representative from the ACLU New
Hampshire was attached to that email so
I haven't seen anything from ACLU
regarding this bill
representative about leckis and then
representing Belcher
this just as a quick response I have
heard from numerous students about
issues including not that was the first
I heard about that issue but um
including when I first got elected
people came specifically to me to report
what was going on at their universities
but
things
administrators change administrations
change cultures change some schools are
doing better in our state some schools
are slipping the other direction
opposite of the way they were
but do you remember the testimony of the
person who said in their state
they said oh we don't have this need
even though they had the opportunity to
pass it and then things blew up like two
years later and they said we wish we
would have passed it when it wasn't an
issue because now it's an issue and we
don't even have anything on the books to
help us through it and so the idea is to
pass this now
while we don't have as much of an issue
as we did in the past
so that hopefully we won't have two
years from now or next year or whenever
an issue because this will be on the
books at a time when we're not
mid-conflict it's much easier to pass
so first one we'll quickly
representative
lad as a member of the
College Council
trustees trust whatever that term is yes
you being that person
um is there a perspective from your view
from that umbrella group
the trustees I can't speak for the
trustees because I'm a single just like
a single selectman can't speak for the
select board the trustee you've seen
this issue Army or the trustee you've
seen this issue
as an issue
I I've not discussed this issue as a
trustee with other trustees I have not
seen it on the docket okay thank you
representative Belcher thank you Mr
chair I just wanted to quickly address
the issue of the disparaging remarks
that we had heard about and the issue of
free speech
um we need to be very clear about who
whose speech is being protected here
because the people have Free Speech but
government does not have free speech so
when somebody is acting as an agent of
the government such as on a school
honest public school council or board or
whatever they don't have the right to
free speech you just disparage
Christians or anyone else as they as
they see fit they that's actually
discrimination
um so we need to be very careful about
who is whose speech is being protected
further discussion wait okay represent
luno yeah thank you very much on the
subject of discrimination and let's talk
about that so looking at
bottom of page two line 36.
and 37 going through the top of page 3
down to line six and what that reads is
that
no institutions for higher ed shall deny
a religious political or ideological
student organization any benefit blah
blah blah blah
based on the expression of the
organization including so this is no
Institute of higher education shall deny
student organization including any
requirement that the leaders are members
of such organizations we're not talking
about the student organization affirm
and adhere to that organization
sincerely held beliefs comply with the
organization's standard of conduct or
further the organization's Mission or
purpose as defined by the student
organization so what that is saying is
that is that the student organization
um would um would would
they have to be would have to be
recognized by The Institute of higher
education and that student organization
would through this Clause right here be
absolutely capable
um of discriminating based on protected
classes of um of you know we've talked
about them about about them here I think
we all know what we're talking about and
um and that's that's blatant
discrimination and that's blatantly
putting the university system and the
community college system in a place
where where they
um you know if they if they provide
organizations with I don't know what it
is 200 500 something something like that
that they would have to provide
organizations that discriminate
um
um based on
protected classes both federally and in
state law
um uh with uh with taxpayer money I I
would suggest that that may be the
reason why lines 24-26 are in there
which is the severability clause in this
but uh but clearly clearly I think any
of us who who believe in in
um in non-discrimination
would would feel that
the provisions from page two down lines
36 through 37 and at the top of Page
Three lines one through six would uh
would need to be um stricken from
um this bill
representative cordelli
um I disagree
um I think uh if you look at our Human
Rights Commission statutes there is a
religious exemption
um so that religious exempt religious
um
have members who
abide by their faith adhere to their
faith
um I I don't know if
the one of these groups the FEC
um you know would want uh atheists
as members of their group maybe that
group might because they were pretty
much non-denominational as I recall but
um there is in statute a religious
exemption
yeah
okay uh we we still haven't done
anything on the amendment yet and that's
just a one-word Amendment so what we
ought to do is try Park that away one
way or the other and then then we can go
on and have a discussion wherever that
takes us
so
um is is there any further discussion on
the amendment
the one word association organization
okay Madam clerk will you please call
the roll on the
Amendment we do have a motion that was
made by represent McDonald on that
Amendment
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative Lucas
yes representative Ford yes
representative Belcher yes
representative Drive yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative paternal yes
representative Corey Taylor yes
representative Miler no
representative Cornell nope
representative Tanner nope
representative Luna no representative
Ellison no representative Wilcox nope
representative hall now representative
Balboni no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon
no
chairman LED yes
10 years 10 days
okay now we're ready for further
discussion on this bill as ought to pass
representative cordelli uh thank you as
mentioned previously
um in chapter 354 a the state commission
for human rights the exemption is
354-a colon 18 exemption for religious
organizations
it says nothing contained in this
chapter shall be construed to borrow any
religious or non or denominate
denominational institutional
organization or any organization
operated for charitable or educational
purposes which is operated by supervised
buyer controlled by or in conjunction
with a religious organization from
limiting admission to or giving
preference to persons of the same
religion or denomination or from making
such selection is as is calculated by
such organization to promote the
religious principles for which it is
with
where where is where is the
discriminatory
section in there
I mean you you know I I think contained
in this chapter shall be construed to
fire any religious organization from
doing any of those things that was
written under exceptions
when we were looking at that whole
area and this is an exception where you
can do certain things right but there's
also renting a property and right right
and anybody can can can can can can do
those things but you but it's not saying
that you can discriminate against
um against others and and and in the in
the section that I cited here
um uh yes it would it would apply to to
any of the protected classes whether
that's religious or whether that's race
or whether that's gender or gender
entity or or ethnicity if you wanted to
have a a student organization that was
um for white people only then and um and
in order to um to to and and you put in
to receive
funds from the University system they
couldn't deny you those funds
um and they could not require you to um
to to accept
you know people who maybe didn't comply
maybe didn't fall into the white guy
only uh category and um and and because
it says here that um that the member
that the uh
that you that the university system or
the community college system would not
be able to have any requirement that the
leaders or members of such organization
um uh affirming
make sure every
no public interest shall deny and then
all the words
um based on
any requirement that leaders or or of
such organization uh affirm and adhere
to that organization sincerely held
belief let's say they're sincerely held
belief or thing beliefs are things that
we find abhorrent and and our and and
um uh and discriminate against uh
protected classes the university system
would still have to recognize that as a
um as a as a student
organization and and so I I'll I'll I'll
I'll defer to representative cordelli
when it comes to the the religious
exemption uh language in the um human
rights statute but uh but again I'm not
quite sure how that language relates to
what's uh what's being put forth here
with respect to um clearly something
that would allow an organization to
discriminate
against protected classes I have a
question maybe uh either somebody here
can help me or maybe Mr Cronin can we
know that on a number of universities
including ours we have Greek fraternity
sororities
and when I was up at Orono we had the
agriculture
fraternity I can't remember what the
Greek nomenclature was for that
um
uh but they had sort of the requirement
built in
that in order to be a member of this you
had to be an AG major or you had to be a
farmer
um if if I wanted to get in there not
wanting to be either of those or either
okay well as long as you're accepting
you know
yeah as long as you're accepting uh
gender you know you're not denying a
based on gender or any of the other
sure that may have come up somewhere
along the way but perhaps
well I had something else that I wanted
to point out but I do want to just say
so it's okay to discriminate as long as
you're not discriminating against a
protected class so some classes are
I guess more protected than others but
what I what my point was one of the
organizations that came and talked to us
was open to anybody membership wise
their issue with this with what was
being required was that their leader
by the school was they were saying that
the leader could protect you could
completely disagree with them
and they couldn't require that their
leader agreed with the precepts in that
case it was a religious organization and
they wanted their leader to be of that
religion they said the organization and
they were very happy to take anybody
because that was part of the point of
the organization but the leader should
be of the same of of the beliefs of the
thing and just as a
example if you had a young
Democrats on campus facility in an
organization you would not want a
republican to be forced to have a
republican as your leader
just you know because you would want
them to be a Democrat because that's
that was the whole that was the leaders
elected by the members of the
organization
[Music]
the University was not going to grant
them an ability to be on there if they
insisted that their leader was adhered
to their beliefs that's that was
specifically
um that testimony was specifically
towards this piece right here so
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair I I think it's
important to get to the heart of this
issue a little bit when it comes to
these talk about discrimination in
student groups the most appropriate
thing to look at is not is not federal
law or state law it's the Constitution
and once again who has rights in the
Constitution the institution doesn't
have rights therefore it has to treat
people as under sect or under amendment
14 equal protection as well as federal
law anti-discrimination law it has to
treat people equally people however
individual people have rights including
the freedom of Association
and like it or not that does Grant
people individual people the right to
discriminate if they choose to do so
and it just it's it's part of being an
American you don't have to like what
they're doing but you can't get rid of
people because you don't like what you
think you can't deny them equal access
to the institutions because you don't
like what they think
that's that's the difference in
government and people
represent cordelli uh thank you
um just trying to uh
look up it's the uh
I'm sorry I lost my uh
um related to religion
um it provides for
um
leadership of religious student groups
similar to other student groups such as
political student groups the equal
access act permits religious student
groups to allow only members of their
religion to serve in leadership
positions if these leadership positions
are positions that affect the religious
content of the speech at the group
meetings
similar to student groups such as
further discussion
are we ready for the vote
Madam clerk we will call the Google call
rule uh this this is a uh it was a
emotion of hot to pass on 516 route to
the Prima speech and Association of
public institutions fire education that
was made by representative McDonald
Madam clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative cortiello yes
representative miler
no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner nope representative Luna no
representative Ellison no representative
Wilcox no representative Hall Nell
Representative balbooni no
Representative cascadin no
representative Damon no chairman Ladd
yes 10 years 10 days
yes
because uh this this is an important
issue
and there are obviously some problems
that we've got with some of the
languages been pointed out in our
discussion
I would move to retain this bill when I
would assume that uh Mr Cronin would be
willing to work with uh the group to try
to look at this language to see if we
might be able to ferret something out of
the language so I would I would move to
retain is there a second second
person uh Myler proposes we retain this
bill second by representative Damon
further discussion
from either
could we hear from uh uh Mr Clark well I
think we know where the the universities
already let us know that where they feel
on this bill okay so I thank you
over the fall try and bring something
back late fall early next year we're
committed to sitting down our legal
council and we apologize same trying to
work for something that you feel like
could move forward and also try and move
this issue along as opposed to uh
perhaps continue in conversation
thank you
so with that Madam clerk would you
please call the rule
Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative blackis no representative
forward
no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
Representative cortielo no
representative Myler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 years 10 days
listen chair I'll move itl
is there a second second
represent uh Tanner second uh reference
on moodle's motion to itl further
discussion Tanner did the second and
Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leckis no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative paternal no
Representative cortiello no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative Wilcox yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yeah chairman Ladd
no
10 years 10 days
okay
we'll write the itl
who was who's writing I will you know
okay we have two bills left we're
skipping over 331 Army okay
um so the first bill would take up is
the next one down 432 relative to
participation in the education Freedom
accounts program four three two
um
did we jump over 61 yeah oh okay I'll go
back up
uh hb61 relative teaching on
discrimination in the public schools and
discrimination and public workplaces uh
representative cordiello you uh I move
in expedient to legislate
is there a second
Belcher can I get the bill up first okay
so we're on HB 61 motions made itl by
representative and
the sponsor on that sponsor of the nick
thank you Mr chair
um so it seems like a really long time
since that hearing over in the big Hall
a lot of people came to that hearing uh
and
what remains clear in my mind is that
there were many
teachers and people who spoke about
teachers and there was
a lot of fear that by teaching on
certain historical topics related to
race that these teachers were risking
their jobs
and for that reason they supported
repealing
the original Law
which just to remind you
is actually if you have your book it's
on page 530 I think it's important to
look at the original Law because this
bill is suggesting that we repeal it
so what are we repealing one of the
things that all so concerned me in the
hearing was that I felt that a lot of
the
people who testified were unfamiliar
with the law that they wanted repealed
there was a disconnect between hb61 and
193.40.
the bill to be repealed
so I think it's very important
um to
understand everything that's in that
bill okay I will read it but I mean
you're probably familiar with it I
certainly studied it I studied it hard
um this bill is really important to me
as far as not having it passed because I
come at this from a sort of a unique
perspective having been a teacher not
just a teacher I was an English teacher
and I actually I feel like I'm in class
again the reason I have these books with
me is they were in my backpack because I
am you know as you know I'm a
assistant Library director and The
Dudley Tucker library now I'm no longer
a teacher I am a teacher though I feel
like in all my capacities I am a teacher
whether I'm a writer or I uh working in
a library or my previous role as an
adjunct English instructor
and so for quite a few years I taught
class in 19th century American
autobiographical literature and for a
month we spent
talking about slave narratives
and Frederick Douglass especially and he
was mentioned at the hearing
in my current position as library
assistant Library director I'm in charge
of programming and um
for my first program I actually chose to
talk about what I know about slave
narratives about a week ago just to kind
of remind me myself of all the the
content
and um
you know ask myself gee should I have
fear being fired and no not at all you
can talk about all the horrors of
slavery and you can talk about all these
subjects okay
um
we've all hoped that there's nothing so
what I found was there was a disconnect
between
hb61
um and the law it seeks to repeal in
fact remember the question kept coming
up with representative leckis introduced
and then I echoed it was asked several
times and nobody that I can recall had a
satisfying answer
as to what in not 193 40.
prohibits the teaching of these subjects
it in fact there was
also a lot of talk about the vagueness
of it
I don't think so I think it's pretty cut
and dry and if not
you'll recall the department I have this
in here I'm I could assume you all have
it the frequently asked questions or
maybe I copied it but on the DOA down
the doe website it actually explains
what
are you prohibited from teaching there's
a question number three does the law
prohibit teachers from teaching US
history no nothing prohibits the
teaching of historical subjects
including but not limited to slavery
treatment of Native American population
Jim Crow laws segregation treatment of
women goes on and on civil rights
movement um black
oh well then it goes on to even say it's
not just historical subjects you can
teach contemporary you can teach on
these current event topics nor does
anything prohibit discussions related to
current events included but not limited
to Black lives matter movement which is
something very you know contemporary
um
so
you know it was a while ago we had that
hearing just wanted to kind of remind
you all get us out there
um it seems to me that supporters of
hb61 want to repeal
RSA 19340 for a reason that doesn't
exist
um and so that
logically would make this inexpedient to
legislate
thank you thank you very much are there
red person cordelli uh thank you uh the
bill also on line 9 repeals uh sections
829-34 of the Human Rights Commission
statutes
um a29 says the general court hereby
fines and declares that practices of
discrimination against any New Hampshire
inhabitants because of age sex gender
identity sexual orientation race Creed
color marital status familial status
mental or physical disability religion
or national origin or a matter of
concern that discrimination based on
these characteristics not only threaten
the rights and proper privileges of New
Hampshire inhabitants but menaces the
institutions and foundations of a free
and Democrat State and threatens the
peace order health safety and general
welfare of the state and its inhabitants
goes on to
um
nothing in this section to be construed
to limit academic freedom nothing in
this subdivision will be construed to
prohibit racial sexual religious uh
sensitivity training
um that is all repealed as a result of
this bill
further discussion president Belcher
thank you Mr chair and I would just
briefly know that the the reason this
law was brought in the first place
is because there was a very real
practice happening and it wasn't oh it
wasn't Universal to all of these sorts
of trainings but in some of these types
of trainings they were devolving into
deeply indoctrinational sessions of
political
religious and ideological concerns that
were being mandated on people on
Children's Schools and employees
in many cases these things mirrored
maoist struggle sessions and it was
completely inappropriate and that is
what this has been to stop you can still
teach
any of these things from a value-neutral
position
you just can't make people feel bad
because of the color of their skin or
their race or gender or anything else
that's what it does
further discussion represent miler
thank you Mr chair oh this all sounds
really nice doesn't it nice and clean
if you talk to a teacher recently
you talked to a teacher recently about
teaching
oh I can talk I can I can uh teach about
slavery I can teach about this but we're
forgetting one important thing here
it's not what I teach
but it's how I pr how I'm perceived when
I'm teaching it
so you've got a group of Liberty women
out here that have a bonus of 500 for
the first one that they take to the
court you've got over in judiciary today
talking about a uh subpoena power for
the our good friend uh the commission of
Education that can bring any teacher
they want to once he gets a call from a
from a parent
just one parent we're not talking about
a group of parents just one parent and
he can subpoena a teacher if this thing
passes
this is this has provided a cloak around
teachers that is that is
suffocating
their ability to basically we talked
about free speech to have some free
teaching here
and this is a very important issue
because we've got a problem of uh I've
asked myself this uh this often what I
have one my would I recommend one of my
kids to be a teacher today
I can honestly say no
because of pressure is like this
the removal of this bill is very
important to the education of our
children notwithstanding what Mr Belcher
said I mean if there was a teacher out
there who was in it nobody wants to have
a children indoctrinated I don't want
that I don't want a teacher next to me
doing that
but that's a management question when
that comes up you don't need a bill to
deal with that
this bill we have to remember how it was
passed
this bill was not before the house
it came before a uh division uh hb2
slicked in there
this just needs to be repealed you just
don't understand the teachers I've
talked with
are fearful
and the last thing I want to do is I
have a teacher out there is that's
fearful of whether teaching if they're
acting out if they're misbehaving there
are procedures to deal with that
particular individual I go back to what
the representative Woodcock said we
don't need a hammer
thank you further questions or
discussion Arlene yes so a parent can
certainly accuse that's gonna you know
they're a parent accused as a teacher
or something related to this
goes to
Court
what again it's the same question that
keeps coming up
193.40 page 530 what in this law
is objectionable
you talk about fear again you talk about
teachers being afraid that's what we
heard over and over again in the
hearings there's a disconnect
cite me some what in this law is
objectionable
further discussion representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair
um and I want to get to uh to to answer
that uh that question that was just put
down
um uh going back to the hearing
um
and I know this is important because I
hear it said
sometimes around this table look at all
the people that came out and testified
look at all the people that that showed
up to uh to tell us what a great idea
this was or this is
um signing on the blue sheets and this
is at the time of the hearing I don't
know where it may have landed 1400
people signed up in support of hb61 20
opposed 45 people spoke in favor six
opposed the um the speakers line up in
favor included members of clergy it
included the ACLU it included
NAACP it included
people from all across the state who
were offended by the limitations that
are being imposed on on public school
teachers by um by the the current state
what was jammed into the current state
budget but um but of the um of of all
the people that that's spoke back on
January 12th at our hearing reps fall
there were a number that that really um
really I think
made strong Impressions but uh but one
that really summed it up very well was
uh Reverend Reverend Gail
um Kenny of Kanan who's um with the um
with the UCC and on the Justice uh board
there and and she's a former School
Board chair and uh and she said you know
House Bill 544 which I think was the
basis for um what was jammed into the
the budget it's part of a national
movement to stoke fear of public schools
and it's not grounded in truth or fact
and here's the part I highlighted and
it's not the words in 544 but it's what
it's doing it's what it's doing to
public school teachers it's what it's
doing
um to to create create a bounty as was
was created by the commissioner of
Education to to to harass
um School teachers around the state and
and it's what this law is doing and
that's what hospital 61 is um looking to
repeal
representative cordelli uh thank you I
was a co-sponsor of House Bill 544 and
it was not meant to intimidate teachers
um it was uh intended to provide
protections
um and uh I know of no bounty on anybody
or anything that's been offered by the
commissioner of Education
represent Tanner absolutely yeah it
wasn't
um by the commissioner it was by a group
a moms group
moms for Liberty thank you
um I personally I've been out of
teaching over a decade now but I still
have some friends that are teaching and
I know of two cases
and that if I know of too there must be
a lot more across the state one teacher
was a teacher of AP History course
who in the last week of her
AP History course before they were going
for their exam
a parent made a complaint to the
Department of Education to our
commissioner who then immediately
initiated an investigation which took
her out of that classroom she was no
longer allowed to teach that AP class or
prepare them for their AP History exam
went on for two weeks the the
documentation that was required
um she was totally exonerated from it
I had another situation
where I attended a school board meeting
and talked to the assistant
superintendent who just spent again
another two weeks
taking a teacher out of a classroom
was uh in Junior High
um on a complete did full investigation
investigation complaint was totally
exonerated
what happens to the other teachers that
are teaching in that building
that sees that happening and that's part
of the that's part of the plan is to
intimidate to say that teachers
inculcate to say that teachers
um compel to express a belief in compel
students to express a belief in to say
we indoctrinate kids I we had a guy here
who was teacher I believe in Concord or
or John Stark who said if only if only
you had that much influence over kids
you can't get them to do things you
can't get them to you know it takes a
lot of activity and a lot of
um
you know professional art to try and
teach kids and have them to totally
understand different situations and and
you use different methods to do that and
there are kids and there are parents who
um are going to have different views on
how things are happening they you might
have a class of 30 and you might have
one or two kids in that class that don't
understand things and so you're you're
trying to work with them separately and
sometimes I mean I've met I've met
students that I taught 30 years ago that
remember things that happened in class
that were really key to to what to
change their thinking or whatever
um
that I had no idea
no idea that I'd even made that
difference and it was positive
difference I mean it was a it was a
young man who was in the service went
into the service right out of high
school he came from a family that didn't
have much money and he was a pretty
bright kid and went into the service and
said he would have never made it through
uh basic training had it not been from
for the media for the exercises we did
in health class on Stress Management
and I know that that that uh I had no
idea
so
um the whole purpose of this of of this
whole thing and you heard it when they
talked about 61 is that it's the
vagueness of this law and the way it's
set up to say no pupil in any public
school in the state shall be taught
instructed inculcated or compelled which
indicates to me that they think that
this law is set up because teachers do
that
and I saw somebody holding a sign out
today trust teachers and teachers and
nurses used to be at the top of the
trust list and if you ask probably
anybody now teaching they feel at the
bottom of the list and the reason
they're at the bottom of the list is not
because they've changed it's because of
the war on public education and the war
on public education teachers and this
bill is like the key to it and that's
why people took time off work we don't
often see teachers in this in this
committee we don't often see students
from public school because they're at
school and they're working okay
that's why we don't see them people took
time off from work value you know they
only get a limited number of days and
they took time off of work to come and
talk and say how bad this bill was
and so if you don't think this bill is
has had an effect on the teaching
um profession in New Hampshire you're
crazy
further questions from represented dry
thank you Mr chairman
I got an email from a neighbor who
is on the other side of the political
fence from me but uh asked Where I Stood
on this bill
and it was not too long after the
hearing
it was preface it by saying that they
respected my integrity
and that really made me want to
investigate this very carefully because
I really did want to do this with a
matter of integrity
uh I sat through the long hearing with
all the rest of you and we got this
last bunch of papers from director
Malachi from the Human Rights Commission
and so I didn't have a chance to go
through it uh until the hearing was over
right so I asked myself a couple of
questions I I too saw the disconnect
between the the people who were
testifying uh of the fear that they had
in the classroom
and but a lot of them I just couldn't in
some ways when they got up to speak I
didn't know whether they were in favor
of the repeal or or not
um but they were just expressing
their experiences uh so I had no idea at
that point what teachers or anybody else
had been given
for instruction
with this law
and so I've finally got to look at this
large section here with the section from
uh attorney formilla and the long page
page after page because it sounded like
there was nothing from the Department of
Ed at all I read this which has a long
section of instruction I went to the doe
website and saw this frequently asked
questions so
I don't know what else they could say
it's right there in black and white
that was a question for me is
um they complained that there was no
instruction I'm looking at the
instruction about it so if you yeah
maybe they need to explain it better I
don't know but I don't know why
you can't read what's in black and white
so I asked this the next question is
okay so is everybody being then taken
into the before the commission on human
rights and I went up to the director at
least I asked her right after the the
Committee hearing and I said what you
know
how many how many cases do you have what
do you got and if she can't tell me the
number but there are some but it didn't
get me the impression that they were
going to be lined up their docket was
full for the next four years it was just
there are some so I asked the next
obvious question I said how many make it
past that first step like a complaint
and she said we have an active case
right now that's been gone past the
prima facie evidence stage and they said
okay so it's not like it's not there
there's evidence that it disappears but
it doesn't to me seem like it is the
overwhelming problem that I was given to
leave or that was feared you know in the
conversation that we had with the public
in the hearing and I have not yet been
satisfied that there's not been any
instruction from the Department of Ed or
the commission on human rights on either
how the Prof process works or what's
available you know what is permitted to
teach and where do you draw the line I
think it's here I don't know how to
connect the two sides
but I I have asked myself every question
that I thought of to ask and I have
Satisfied by myself that
there are answers to those questions so
I'm coming down the fact that I don't
think we need to repeal this
maybe we need to work on
how to address the fears of people that
are in the classroom
thank you representative representative
Belcher
I've been puzzling over this ever since
the first repeal was made last year
I actually
um a teacher that had come up and
everybody loved and said I wished you
were my teacher I had just handwritten
out what the law said and presented it
to him as a just the words and I said so
if I put in this law what would you
think of it and he took it and he said
oh this is excellent this is very good I
said that's the lie you're asking to
repeal really
and and he didn't find any problem with
the words I know the teachers are all
feeling this that's why last year I kept
asking if there's no problem with what's
in the law where is the problem and
finally most people oh well I don't know
nobody could give me an answer until
finally one man said there is nothing
wrong with the law there's nothing wrong
with the words in the law the problem is
all the information that's going on out
there
and
and the information that's going on out
there that's a problem isn't what the
doe put out and it isn't what the
commission for human rights put out so
the question is who is causing all these
teachers to be afraid who is it's not
the law so we're going to repeal a law
because there's all this misinformation
out there if I would a wonderful
precedent to set if I'm a criminal and I
don't like Allah or if I think a law
shouldn't be on the books I just have to
spread all the information
misinformation I want and then we have
to repeal it because everybody's afraid
they're going to break it but the other
part of that was your example of two
teachers
who were taken for two weeks and and
checked to see you know because somebody
complained and they were checked and
they were exonerated this happens
doesn't have to do just with this it can
have to do whatever complaint a parent
has I've seen it with our principal
recently he at a student assembly he did
nothing wrong but somebody complained he
was he was not principal you know then
this is near this is near the start of
the year
he was suspended by the superintendent
until things could be checked on it had
nothing to do with this it was
completely different it happens that's
what you do when somebody complains but
again this year I was listening very
clearly what are the teachers saying
they're afraid they're afraid they're
afraid of losing their job they're
afraid that if somebody
says they made me feel uncomfortable
I'll lose my job and I'm like where is
this coming from the
it's not in the law that they're going
to lose their job because somebody made
them feel uncomfortable if what's in the
law is they go before
the New Hampshire commission for human
rights the United they figure out
whether or not which for the most case
the people the few that have come
have have not even continued on from
that they don't go before the doe and
unless the commission for human rights
finds issues I talked to that lady
afterwards I ask her specifically what
the process was because some teacher
told me no they go before the doe first
I went to the commission and she said no
they do not they do not until the
commission has figured out whether or
not there is reasonable cause or I'm not
sure I got the right words but then they
would go into further and so most have
not as she said there was one that was
pending
so I was asking myself where is all this
fear coming from what goes on at our
colleges
what just happened at one of our
colleges some student felt uncomfortable
because of what a conservative Professor
had said
and the professor was immediately fired
and even the head of his Department said
there was nothing wrong with what he
further discussion representative
Allison Bob I as a former social studies
teacher I I would just
and for those of you who don't think
there's been an impact on instruction in
the state I would say bring 50 randomly
selected social studies teachers from
high schools in the state and come in
here and ask them a question do you
asked the question whether or not they
have changed what they're doing in the
classroom and you won't like the answer
president or represent Damon you had
your hand up to
I don't know thank you Mr chair
so my dad who's 93 years old and still
intact of Mind although frail
is retired social studies teacher
and I am here partly because he taught
I'm here partly because he taught how to
be a critical thinker
how to take information from different
points of view
I had him as a teacher when I was a
seventh grader I don't think that
happens these days but
three out of my four siblings and I had
he would bring for example articles from
the Christian Science monitor this was
and bring
all sorts of resources from all
different points of view for us to read
an I've had conversations with him quite
a few this winter
about this bill
and said could you teach the way you
used to teach
comfortably and feeling safe with your
ear teaching credentials and he said and
my dad was a really committed teacher
and then served on his school board for
20 years after he retired
education is at his heart and soul
and he said I wouldn't have still been a
teacher that's what our teachers are
facing today we need to repeal this law
representative Cornell
just to maybe wipe um teachers or find
what came out following the state's
establishment of a website to report
violations of a new anti-divisive
subject law the New Hampshire chapter of
moms for Liberty tweeted that it would
pay 500 to the first person to
successfully catch a teacher breaking
the new law
and
well that's just they did put out a
bounty on teachers if you could catch
them and report them on the state's
website they'd give you five hundred
dollars so I think that would add
something to teachers being afraid of
what they're teaching in class because
there's bounties on them
representative
thank you first of all I feel really
badly that teachers feel that way and I
am acutely aware that there are multiple
of professions that feel like they are
under profoundly intense scrutiny these
days so it's certainly not just teachers
who are experiencing that but I've had
I've been really thinking long and hard
I had a conversation when I was um
canvassing
I had somebody ask me how I felt about a
certain class of people and I literally
answered him I said it's really sad that
we have to enumerate certain groups of
people in our constitution because if we
all treated each and every person like a
human being we wouldn't be looking at
them as groups of people
so and was trying to summarize
193.40 and thank you representative dry
for reminding me about the frequently
asked questions page on the doe website
which was made in conjunction with the
commission for human rights and
Department of Justice
and they have a little text box that
says in short do not teach that a person
or a group is inherently oppressive
Superior inferior racist or sexist
teach and treat all equally and without
discrimination and that summarizes it
all in two sentences if you just treat
each and every person like a human being
we wouldn't need 193.40 we wouldn't need
the second part of article two which was
amended in 1974 and we wouldn't be
fighting this right now thank you
further discussion represent Belcher
you've heard that teachers have so
little influence over students that they
can't possibly get them to do anything
in the classroom but they also have so
much influence over them that they can
touch them and change their lives
we've heard that this law is totally
unnecessary because these things just
don't happen and they're not being done
yet it's so stifling that teachers
cannot possibly do their jobs while this
law is in place
we've heard that teacher trust is at an
all-time low
but we've heard that nothing has changed
in education but I want to challenge
that last part that nothing has changed
in education
over the last 20 plus years Paulo Fieri
has become one of the most cited
individuals in education colleges with
his books the politics of education and
pedagogy of the oppressed
over the last same period of time
critical theories and post-modernism has
been imported into our schools in
various ways
it is leading to problems with children
and is leading the problems with
teachers
I don't think any of them want to be
dealing with this stuff
it's that's where we're at right now and
that's why we have to put these
protections and keep these Protections
in place until we can fix the underlying
problems for now we absolutely need to
keep this
thank you further discussion
representative Tanner
I just don't live in your world
that's for sure
because
you know you you see everything in Black
and White and it's not black and white
and neither is teaching and teaching
teaching students at a variety of
students from a variety of backgrounds
not only in social studies but in other
skills other skill areas or other
teaching areas teaching English teaching
fiction uh letting them read books like
to Kill a Mockingbird and then you know
now that it's on the banned list or one
of the books to be banned
um I bet if you think back to your
school time that there were different
times when you read books or you had a
exercise in class perhaps or even you
had a research paper where whatever you
as you were growing up had a big
impression upon you and you came into
class and you were able to bounce ideas
back and forth with the teacher that's
really important
once you set it up so that
anybody that that that feels the least
little bit complaint
can can make you lose your job I mean
when I was teaching you lost your job if
you were immoral
insubordinate or incompetent
those were the three things that's in
the book as well and all of a sudden now
it's if if I run an activity where some
kid goes home and says wow I feel like
you know I'm inferior to
to some other class
and the parent goes absolutely Bonkers
and sends a complaint to the Department
of Education and the department of
education does get the complaints and
they refer them over to either the AG's
office or to the office of Human Rights
and yes the office of human rights does
investigate some of those but while
that's going on
at the local school district the person
is suspended from their classes maybe
with pay maybe not although mostly
probably with pay but they they lose
that two weeks of teaching they're under
under scrutiny I mean how would you like
to have that happen to you just get
yanked out and say okay somebody made
this complaint now you have to justify
your teaching you have to justify what
you did you have to get
a lawyer probably because your
livelihood depends upon it if they take
away your teaching credential
your whatever money you've spent for
college whatever you've dedicated your
life to is taken away from you
that's why this this bill is so serious
so so seriously bad
if I may just respond to that one piece
real quick
um you brought up a good point which is
Teachers would lose their jobs for being
immoral
but then you gave the example of if a
student feels bad because they're part
of some class if they're made to feel
bad and I just want to say that teaching
child to feel bad because of a Class A
skin color is deeply immoral
I'm talking about reading a book Like To
Kill a Mockingbird and realizing that at
that I lived in a community that was all
white
I never had contact with black people
and when I read that book I felt bad
about it
that's and and I should and it was a
learning experience for me and that was
that's a learning experience that's
something that
that made me a better person and made me
understand the world better out of my
little provincial little area
foreign
thank you I just how many of you have
been in a staff meeting like lately with
public school teachers how many of you
have sat in the lunchroom with public
school teachers and asked about this law
this is known from the teachers feel as
the band Concepts law
I just challenge you to go talk to
teachers before you make a decision
represent miler
thank you Mr chair I just want to pick
up on a point that representative Tanner
talked about the issue here is is the is
the law but it is the perception
in other words if I feel one way about
the result of it that's one thing but
another person say I don't like what you
just did I compile a complaint it is it
is the the ability
to bring people to to tasks when they're
doing what they've been doing for years
and an individual can do that we just
had a situation here in Concord
where a person a convicted felon goes in
and complains about an art teacher here
in town because the way he dressed and
he automatically gets he automatically
gets an investigation the kids love them
the parents love them but this one
person because he didn't like the way
that person dressed caused a complaint
had nothing to do with his teaching
that is the problem here it's the
perception that people have of what's
happening and as representative Tanner
said if a child goes home and says you
know I really felt uncomfortable nobody
else in class felt uncomfortable a
parent can compile a complaint
that's that's the that's the onerous
situation that's happening in education
today on this issue that's why this
needs to be repealed
representative woodcock
Mega trim a lot
um
a few days ago we're talking about the
school board public hearings public
meetings
and the reality was we're talking about
covet
and masking
this law reminds this this bill reminder
that uh same way
when this came before us uh and as a
overabundance of critical race Theory
dialogue
that's where it came from
and what we heard people say was
sitting there racism is real in this
state
we need to promote conversation
we heard people say
when teachers can make students feel
safe they can talk more and have more
risks and more learning that's what we
heard we heard the Manchester school
boys saying over this law is consciously
or unconsciously causing credibility
issue with our teachers and the public
teachers are professionals
we need to allow them to work their work
in the classroom and help students grow
help students how to learn to discuss
and until we open that range of
opportunity
then we can make teachers make teaching
a profession that people do not want to
go in and are untrusted we need to start
correcting this and this is not doing it
this is this is an impingement on public
education it
curtails dialogue it curtails Innovation
it makes us teach a narrow view of
history and I don't think this is uh
helpful I understand the intent may seem
like there's nothing in the law that
says that's that is bad you can just
talk around the issues that's not the
reality in the classroom thank you Mr
chair you're welcome Jefferson Hall
thank you
um I I would take those 20 social
studies teachers that representative
elephants talked about and I would also
ask them if two years ago did they know
what CRT was did they know a divisive
Concepts were I think every one of them
we're dancing around a number of
different things in this discussion
probably at the core of it is the
critical race Theory teaching which is
currently caught in most of the
universities as fact not as Theory as
fact
and then the teachers who are taught
that go into the schools and teach it as
fact
but it's not fact
it's Theory generated out of the Harvard
a sociology lab now what are you doing
here I've taken a lot of lab courses
none in sociology
we have a hypothesis which is just an
idea of speculation
you test it against things you determine
what is a truth or what is fact
you don't take what is an assumption or
something worth thinking about
that's the primary flaw critical race
Theory
it assumes that because some white
people
were
um
involved in racial and other kinds of
deprivation
that white people do that
you're drawing a generalization from a
particular fact
all white people are not racist because
some white people have been a racist
Aristotle yes I know he was a white male
it's a reasoning
playing in some
and people are not taught that
and they're also taught to believe that
because people did this of a certain day
that their children are also guilty
I disagree entirely with that I lived in
I lived in racially segregated school
areas
I lived in towns where the black people
lived down the street and the white
I lived in the world where
black people weren't allowed to carry
knives they could only carry personal
Improvement things so They Carried
razors strapped around their neck
the woman who reared me as a child had
to carry an ice pick because it was
illegal to carry a knife
I learned that at age six when she was
cleaning out her purse one day at the
yes there are some terrible evil heinous
horrible whatever work word you want
things that happened in that
but people did not become racist
because their father our parents or
grandparents or whatever was a racist
not everybody
I'm sure some did they're humans
but I was at a camp one night run by the
and we were having to find ways to get
the black campers back to their homes
because people were rioting and burning
down The Parks
and they were trying to get these black
so all those generalizations just stick
in my crawl
I don't like sloppy reasoning and I
particularly don't like it when it
and whether they're teachers in some
research our students
they don't need to be taught that they
what's wrong with some portion of this
law is they're talking about teaching on
what the hell does teach on me
does it mean explain learn about
understand
just on the subject of
it needs to be explicit
and it be there needs to be explicit at
and yes not all teachers are taught
logic
how many teachers in New Hampshire teach
without having studied a foreign
language teach that in English
I dropped the pencil my fault
but in Spanish it just fell
it just fell
and so you try to teach a kid who speaks
Spanish to convict himself of fault
without understanding that he thinks of
it that way
are you prepared to teach that student
no
but there's no foreign language
requirement in any uh education program
probably in this state and in many many
others
but the point about this is we really
need to be more explicit more honest
and there's not nearly enough research
has been done about what it's like to
live in a racist Society
but I can tell you there's a lot more
if you grow up as I did and many of you
did with a parent who's in a small
business
you dared not speak out lest your entire
your father's business would shrink
so is that racist is that fear
is that what
I don't know I don't know I have the
answer for that but I've lived it
it's real
and when you start telling me Oh people
were racist just because because
you're not convincing me
I've met the real died in the wood scary
racist
and the simplistic teaching just doesn't
cut it and that's not the fault of the
teacher is what they were taught
it's less than honest universities
universities who are not doing research
they want to be professors
but they train as teachers
and then they stop professing they stop
doing research
the real flaw in the universities is
they don't require the professors to do
research and publish you publish to
expose your ideas to the criticism of
other people in the field
to test them to challenge them to prove
whether or not you really should teach
that
there's where the flow is
the teachers are not well served because
they're not as well taught as they
thank you are there any free is there
not seeing any uh yes reps and cordial
one last thought because I'm I'm really
concerned
um where the lawmakers
are we going to judge our laws by how
they make people feel
are we going to judge our laws by the
letter of the law what is in here now I
asked a question like I don't know it
seems like an hour ago a long time ago I
said what in 193 40s objectional
objectionable representative Tanner
started reading Roman numeral one but I
mean that's just no people in any public
school in the state shall be taught
instructed inculcated or compelled and
then you sort of stop
the Crux of it is it sort of leaves you
hanging it's hot what and then you have
a b c d where what's wrong
tell me somebody because if you can't
further discussion
okay I think we're ready to go into the
voting stage of this so it's
hb61 relative teaching on discrimination
in public schools and discrimination in
public workplaces
and the motion on the table is to what
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative blackis yes
representative Ford yes representative
yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
yes
representative cortiello yes
representative miler
representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no representative
Luna no representative Ellison no
representative
representative Hall no Representative no
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no
chairman yes
10 years 10 days motion yes represent
miler
I move octopass is there a second second
represent out can you say that or I'm
sorry to start it oh uh represent Myler
made the motion to
OTP and represent Woodcock made the
motion to Second it yes sir yep thank
you
yep okay please chairman cordelli
no
representative Lucas no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative no Representative
courtiello no representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner
yes
everything luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
no
and
person cordelli doing the accordion oh
huh
okay
um we have two bills left and three or
yeah so let's take about five minutes
for people to get up and stretch those
um yeah
um
see which ones we have 432 446 and the
bathroom one we did we only have two
left right
let me see two 331 we're putting that
off anyways we're skipping that today so
at least 432 and 446 yeah right so we
only have two builds left
foreign
on both of them
okay we have uh itl on the first one and
the second we have ought to pass for the
amendment
right and I've got one
yes
um yes okay folks we're ready to go
ahead with the we have these two bills
left HB 432 is a bill relative to the
participation in the education Freedom
accounts program
um
331 we're holding that off because of
the see what happens in the house floor
tomorrow
with the similar bill
so HP 432
representative cordelli he recognized
representative Belcher makes the motion
to second second that
representative cordelli made the motion
yes
just like being on the airplane
representative Hall
okay representative cordelli
um this this bill requires uh their
family
um have their um uh income
eligibility checked uh annually
um I think that's going to be a hardship
for uh some families who have
um income that might go up and down in a
real estate agent
Etc
um and uh
possibly make the child a yo-yo in terms
of being kicked out of the program than
being allowed in ETC based on the
Family's income that fluctuates
uh uh further discussion from yeah we
we're just going to keep it so we'll
just be representative cordelli and me
right and then we'll go okay I was just
going to cool with a second of it yes we
can do that what we've agreed upon in
this bill because we know where we're
going on it is that it's going to be
just two people speaking representing
Cornelia and representative luno and
then we're going to go into the voting
mode
result
and then we probably won't need any
speeches on the next motion so so
um what uh what representative cordelli
said is that uh that this bill does in
fact require annual income
recertification
um for families with students in the um
in the education Freedom account uh
program it doesn't make any change with
respect to what that income level is but
it's an annual recertification the same
thing that we do with Medicaid and snap
and so many other programs
um that that once they're um but but the
difference the difference is that with
um uh with annual income certification
here
um
if your your income Rises and you no
longer qualify for the for the state
voucher you're the student doesn't get
bugster it doesn't get kicked out of
school or anything like that when that
happens when you're in Medicaid or snap
you get kicked out of Medicaid you get
kicked out of snap
um uh but uh but the the student does
not get kicked out of their um of their
their uh you know private private school
and um and so uh so you know for for for
these reasons for fairness for taxpayer
fairness and consistent with um with the
governor's comments that um that uh that
he supports reasonable guard rails on
the um the EFA program
um uh I hope people will defeat the itl
and will support an OTP thank you thank
you very much
did you already had your little speech
so Madam Clerk what we're going to do
now is uh uh take action on the motion
so it's chairman cordelli
yes
representative blackis
yes representative Ford yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative paternal
yes representative Court yellow yes
representative Miler no
representative Cornell
representative Tanner no representative
Luna no representative Ellison no
representative rep is a new Hall no
representative Balboni no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman yes 10 years 10 days
okay represented my uh luno do you have
a motion yes thank you Mr chair I'll
move ought to pass
we have a motion on the floor
um ought to pass made by representative
discussion representative yeah
so right to vote
when you're ready Madam Clerk uh Vice
chairman cordelli no
Representative leckis no representative
board no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
Representative cortielo no
representative Myler yes representative
Cornell
yeah yes
I called you this time representative
Tanner yes
representatively now yes representative
Ellison representative Wilcox yeah
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
no
10 years 10 years so somebody will write
okay from representative Court Kelly for
the itl
all righty so now we're down to uh four
four six this is relative participation
in the education Freedom accounts
program by students with disabilities we
representative Cardella you recognize
for a motion
uh yes I'd like to move out to pass and
offer an amendment
777. McDonald said that oh
okay
um
would you like to offer that uh yeah I'd
I like to pass
now the motion I got a system made we
need to have a second on that motion
zero zero seven seven seven eight it's
an amendment presented by representative
okay that's good okay Mr chair yeah just
so that because I think there's two
amendments right that are going to be
proposed yes before we take votes on any
amendment can we can we have discussion
on on two on the two amendments I see no
reason why not okay thank you
yes I have one other amendment that was
earlier oh there's another one in there
too yeah
I'll just explain my amendment is fixing
my other Amendment because the RSA was
wrong and Jen caught it because it's
supposed to be RSA 194 Dash F colon 4
not B so my amendment was just fixing
the B to an F
so so
let's have let's just have uh represent
cordelli explain his Amendment and then
education Freedom account allows for
many different options for parents for
educational uh options
um uh anything from homeschooling to
online courses a private school
Etc and each have different
ramifications in terms of services for a
child with disability so it gets very
complicated even a private school
placement by the parent has different uh
criteria different abilities or Services
uh based on whether the private school
is profit or non-profit
um
so I I thought the simplest approach
for everybody involved was to have the
Bureau of special ed write up an
explanation of the rights for students
with disabilities who take an EFA and go
through all those options
um in the explanation they come up with
rather than us trying to do it in
statute
okay represent Cornell can you please
explain years then mine was just I think
more specific to one
um
group of
schools that parents might Place their
um
students with a disability and mine just
specifically dealt with for-profit
private schools which don't have to
um which don't have to provide any kind
of special ed services and my concern
was that parents have be told that and
be aware of it before placing their
children there and actually as long I
guess rep cordelli will have to fix the
B to an F
um because we're on RSA but I I think
that would be taken care of in the
enrollment process but as I guess I have
no
cordelli's Amendment as long as it it's
listed out that the for-profit you know
every placement is explained I I guess I
have no problem with that because you
you should cover for-profit for
non-profit though
um uh this whole process of dividing the
federal income for that Resident School
District dividing by the number of
special edu students that one or two
students who go into the private school
they get a percentage based on the
division about the federal income and
they get a service plan and so it it
gets rather involved as opposed to
students who take a different EFA option
yeah
actually if the nonprofit the non-profit
if there are six students and four of
them have one disability and two of the
other but all the money is taken up by
the four the other two don't get any so
if that's all written out and given to a
parent before they do it
I'm okay with that
so a further discussion from
representative I see your hand thank you
Mr chair
um has um I I I believe
um
uh representative Cornell's amendment I
think was was was that drafted in in
coordination with um with attorneys
Allen
or with with Bonnet with Bonnie uh
Dunham so so somebody that that
specializes in in special education and
special education law and I was
wondering if the same thing was done
um with representative
um cordelli's uh amendment I I got
um uh right up from uh Rebecca Fredette
about the different options for private
school placing placement based on
whether it's for-profit or non-profit
and at that point I decided
let me take a step back and let them
write it up and if anything changes
they'll take care of the maintenance of
the instruction manual for the special
ed students thank you that that clears
so before we go anywhere then uh let's
just have sort of like a general
consensus uh where where are folks
leaning right now in terms of which
amendment
yes
but in uh representative cordelli's
Amendment
so is this a written explanation that
the department would come up with one
written statement that addresses
everything or is this a different
statement for different student
situations I was not clear from what you
said right
um an explanation of the rights for all
the education options that are available
under the EFA program so it'd be one
document right
thank you for clarifying
because when the scholarship
organization hands out this document the
parent might not be sure at that point
which option and whether it's a private
school that's for-profit or non-profit
or Etc
follow-up yes
so then I may have misunderstood what
representative Cornell just said
when you were speaking about if there
were six students and four had one
situation and two had another
that if the four were paid for there
wouldn't be there might not be enough
left for the other two did I hear that
correctly and so
I'm wondering if one document applies to
all students it sounds like it depends
it's the way the the federal funds are
distributed for special ed in placements
so so it's not the same funding process
that you have for our students in
regular Space special ed in a public
school
the money that's divided up is just the
federal funds they're from PI so I
understand that okay may I have one more
yes sure
so I'm trying to understand how one
standardized document is going to inform
a parent
what will and will not be covered for
their particular student
it just sounds like it's different in
different circumstances am I incorrect
about that
uh yes it's based on what education
option the uh parents the parent chooses
for their child
the options would be different in terms
of the services available or not
available
but I I think it can be done in a
one-page document
the document I got from uh uh special ed
director for debt for private schools
was like two-thirds of a page
thank you represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and it's a little
late today so I just want to take a look
at this and make sure I'm seeing this
correctly and you can correct me if I'm
mistaken here
I'm looking at um rep Cornell's
Amendment
um bidding on line five
it says participation participation in
the EFA program is a parental placement
under 20 USC and now let's skip down to
line eight starting at the end a
parental placement under idea means a
parental placement by blah blah the
definition of an elementary school under
20 USC section 14016 so when I go to
that
it defines an elementary school and an
uh as a non-profit institution is that
is that the correct thing that this
wouldn't have the effect of limiting
disabled students to using efas only in
but I I think not wanting to speak for
representative I think the intent is
that um it would provide
um the explanation for how the services
are to be provided if it's a non-profit
private school it doesn't say
um non-profit there but um it it's
non-profit in the definitions that are
included in the uh Amendment yeah
and Mr chair yes so so
um you know I obviously I've learned a
lot about what or and I'm learning a lot
about what all these different options
can be so so I can I appreciate rep what
representative cordelli is trying to do
in terms of not not
only providing
um what uh what a student's rights may
be in certain options but in all the
options and I think it does get
complicated quickly when uh when an EFA
student maybe a part-time student in
their resident School District maybe a
full-time student in a public school dis
in a out of District public school and
then in a private school for profit in a
private school non-profit in a home
school
and then of course all combinations of
those where they may be a part-time
student in their resident Public School
District and and I think that they
probably have different rights under
idea and and the and there's probably
other combinations of things too so so I
think it probably is beyond the um the
you know I I I think it it it it sits
with should sit with the expertise
um of uh of somebody that
you know it's doing this and can update
it right so so so I I change yeah right
right and and um and capabilities too
and so I I would um uh representative
Cornell sounds
supportive of Representative cordelli's
Amendment and uh and you know I would be
supportive of that too
yes representative dry thank you Mr
chairman so
um if this is kind of a generalized
explanation am I correct that uh a
parent could take their special case to
the person who is in charge of special
education support there to find out the
the details for their particular child I
I'm sure in addition the department
has been appropriated funds for an EFA
administrator they've been having
difficulty finding someone for that
position but I'm sure that person would
act as an interim intermediary to
getting the special ed director involved
any further discussion from the
committee
so we do have a motion on the table and
it was motionless made for the
777h amendment
if there's no and so that's the one
we're going to be acting upon at this
point in time
um so um Madam clerk would you please
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative penernal yes
representative Corey tiello yes
representative miler
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Wilcox representative
Paul yes representative Balboni yes
representative Cascade and yes
representative Damon
chairman Ladd yes 20 years okay so now
we need a motion of ought to pass as
amended with that particular Amendment
you want to make it and then we'll have
representative Cornell second it ought
to pass cemented
um
we have representative cordelli and and
representative Cornell
hmm
so he had enough enough of those today
no I do get some more but you might got
more okay
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative blackis yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald no
representative Noble yes
representative Peter now yes
representative courtiello yes
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes
representative Ellison
representative Wilcox yes
representative Hall yes representative
yes representative cascad and yes
representative Damon yes
chairman lad yes 19 years one day any
so we are done everything we're going to
do today but before we all depart I'd
like to make sure that you're aware that
those reports got get into me I
understand it's gonna it's it's been
late last several days and we got a
session of our own summer preparing for
that as well so I will need these
reports uh by hopefully on up Friday at
noon
so please get get them done and get them
into me uh either send them to myself or
to represent Myler that'd be fine and
then we'll get them over to Lindsay so
she can be working on them
I guess that's it anything else just for
um just for updates the uh we do have
committee next week
um
and no uh but no no out session
is that correct that is correct and
we're carrying forward one bill that we
did not do
so that will carry forward to the MonDay
session and that that is HB 331
and that will add on to those bills
um take a look at those bills that we
have coming up uh there there are some
bills that everybody should be have some
familiarity with because uh
they are relative to dissemination
obscene materials by schools and
institutions of Higher Learning relative
education Freedom accounts relative
withdrawal from a corporate School
District establishing local education
Freedom account program there's a number
of those relative to the vaccinations
clinics at schools another one dealing
with free School meals limiting
education Freedom account budget funding
to budgeted amounts and repealing the
collection of State education property
tax
and then on Wednesday There's a number
it just doesn't want to stop on us
um
Yeah Tuesday is the voting day correct
right
and so we tried to stay away from that
so if we can get these bills taken on
those two days
if and we're going to have to we're
going to have to get those bills done by
Wednesday because we won't have them in
next week not next week first is the
next I think yeah first or 22nd it's
still up in the air I believe yeah
so Thursday Thursday is off but be aware
that anything we don't do on that Monday
it's going to get dumped into Wednesday
and we'll have to stay here on Wednesday
yeah it's a little late but we may want
to recognize that it is international
women's day oh yeah today is
international women's day so for all you
International women congratulations
and if anybody wants to attend the work
session on school building Aid that's on
Friday at 10 o'clock on Monday someone's
going to have to do the green sheets